Dr maau former member of the SCP
foundation's 05 Council had one sworn
enemy one being that he despised more
than anything else in the entire
universe the being known as SCP uu the
monster that had eliminated death and
destroyed the world the vengeful doctor
was able to successfully go back in time
to the days before
scpu first manifested desperate to
prevent the Horrors witnessed during
ubu's centuries long Rampage after the
SCP Foundation failed to help him with
his plan Dr moud spent thousands of
years reestablishing project Beluga in
this new timeline the project secured
ownership of Kango Greenland evacuated
the civilian population and constructed
Beluga 1 in the epicenter of ubu's
manifestation point it was outfitted
with 100 high yield nuclear weapons heat
amplification runes copied from from SCP
NSF a targeting Beacon for SCP dag and
five antimatter Gathering pods from SCP
H&M the Trap was set and it was time to
wait for SCP ubu to appear when it did
and the trap was sprung SCP ubu managed
to escape unharmed rampaging through the
world much like it did the first time
that attempt failed but it was not the
only one Dr maau was not about to give
up now he restarted the cycle again
using replicates in order to gain a
greater amount of control over both the
SCP Foundation and the global cult
Coalition 25 years before SCP ubu's
scheduled arrival Dr maau opened
email-based Communications with SCP
2803a P Hudson gawk a giant tumorous
blob of Flesh in an abandoned anomalous
office building with the genus Mind of a
former CEO regarding the threat he
informed gawk that in 25 years time
something was going to destroy the
entire global economy particularly the
Consumer Electronics Market this
massively distressed as CP
2803a at this point Dr Macau asked if
the anomaly might have a skill set that
could help prevent ubu from destroying
the economy and of course the rest of
the world SCP
2803a as it turns out did indeed have a
strategy in mind one year before ubu's
arrival 28 3-a attacked parasitized and
fused with SCP 169 the Leviathan this
Fusion resulted in a creature 1.5 times
the original size of SCP 169 with
several heads the resulting collateral
damage was catastrophic killing billions
of civilians when the creature came face
to face or faces with ubu it lasted
centuries before ubu made the killing
blow maow repeated the cycle again and
again and again and again in some Cycles
he tweaked his plans by the tiniest of
degrees other Cycles were dramatically
different from the ones that came before
during cycle 273 he increased the
aperture from the Beluga 94 project
teleporting the entire continent of
Greenland into another dimension after
ubu first appeared both Greenland and
ubu vanished on 512
2588 however only 5 minutes later a
second ubu material ization event
occurred the Rampage continued on from
there Dr maau was becoming discouraged
and considered modifying his Central
Consciousness containment unit to
forcibly redirect any negativity he felt
away from himself and his abilities and
toward ubu during cycle 530 macod
established site assembly in Cypress in
the year 10,485 BC the Beluga X unit was
constructed over the course of 3,000
years there this was achieved via the
infiltration of the Church of the broken
God which was converted into the false
pretense Labor division of project
Beluga saric cult activity spread
through Europe as a result but this was
an acceptable amount of collateral
damage What mattered most was the Beluga
x a heavily armed construct based around
the design of SCP 246 the Colossus
replicate 5818 one of the many maow
replicates was selected for the role of
majority Consciousness holder that then
10 minutes after ubu manifested Beluga X
was deployed Beluga X confronted SCP ubu
and declared the intent to stop its
Invasion at the sound of macau's voice
ubu responded with the call sure it
promptly began to whistle the bathtime
song the same one it had whistled so
very very long ago while tormenting Dr
mcod somehow this ubu was the original
one from the very first timeline how did
did it survive how long had it been
following Dr maod who refused to answer
any of these questions Beluga X charged
at ubu but slipped in a pile of the
beast's dung falling to the ground the
cycle was a failure and Dr mcod was
filled with more dread and hopelessness
than ever in cycle 675 the moon's
gravitational pole was increased causing
it to collide with ubu during the
materialization event this Collision
succeeded and the Earth was completely
destroyed there was two much debris to
determine if ubu survived being hit by
the moon or not this was unacceptable to
Dr macod in the following cycle Dr Macau
took a more human approach over the
course of 10 Millennia replicates
forcibly converted 90% of the human
population to an invented religion
called Spade of Triumph also known as
spis the primary mode of worship in spis
was the creation of as many Beluga 900
units as physically possible conflicts
between spis and the rest of the world
religions resulted in many wars and
spads had enslaved 5.9 billion people by
2500 CE by the time ubu manifested there
were still not enough Beluga 900 units
to make a difference cycle 677 was
identical to cycle 530 in every way
until the year 2500 CE at this point
Beluga x mark I was created and piloted
directly by the consciousness of Dr maow
it was first tested on 1225 2500 at
which time Dr Macau destroyed half of
Asia over a period of 8 hours billions
were killed this cycle was not intended
to stop ubu it was a prime numbered
cycle and thus according to macau's own
personal rules was to be used for stress
relief in the form of Senseless
destruction during cycle 678 mow came to
a troubling conclusion he was running
out of resources homed replicators were
broken Beyond repair leaving only 305
replicates where their should have been
Millions SCP 319 could not be secured
and there were no more stolen SCP 2700
cores to make matters worse there were
not enough resources to gather
additional working hominid replicators
from SCP 2000 he would have to make
contact with the SCP Foundation again
and the goal of project Beluga would
have to be modified from termination to
containment he drafted containment
procedures to be implemented the moment
the opportunity presented itself these
containment procedures were unlike any
penned by the foundation before they
were not simply a containment method
they were a punishment they were a
Vengeance to ensure the internal Agony
that Dr mow believed SCP ubu empirically
deserved area ubu was constructed within
scite Beluga metas spatial Mainframe
area ubu is a pocket Dimension where Dr
mcau is God it consists of 1 square
kilometer of wide open nothing Dr MC's
will was capable of causing the area to
repeat at infinum depending on where SCP
ubu moved this essentially meant that
there was no Escape no Edge only
infinite emptiness in M's words no one
to run from him no one to fight him no
one to hurt there would be no death in
this space and it would be equipped with
an indestructible floor Dr macau's plan
Illustrated how this Millennial long
battle had taken a toll on his own
sanity by his plan ubu would be kept in
this uncaring Solitude for as long as it
would take for the futility of his
situation to set in his laughter would
become confusion his confusion would
become anger his anger would become
whimpering his whimpering would become
begging his begging would become sobbing
and his sobbing would become wailing
this process would continue until ubu
began to eventually adjust to its
surroundings once it began to feel
comfortable and began to experience the
smallest glimmer of hope Macau would
implement the next stage of his
containment procedure he would summon a
dark and Mountain High and unspeakably
strong version of himself with fingers
like gleaming scalpel he planned to
destroy ubu in countless ways warping
the monster squishing its body and
molding it like clay then it would only
get worst for the Beast as Dr macau's
plans for Revenge made him just as
horrific a monster as his enemy
according to macau's plans he would
clone ubu a companion a wife the first
real friend he has ever had and maau
will harden her heart and make her
despise him she will reject him cruy and
viciously she will curse the day she
ever met something so objectively
hideous as SCP ubu and if that doesn't
drive the point home enough she would
offer her heart to maod himself
effectively cuckolding his worst enemy
at at this point Macau planned to
destroy the fabricated wife in front of
ubu these procedures were only the
beginning of the intake proceedings
after that maau would move on to one of
148 level two sub routines while writing
these containment procedures Dr maau
smiled for the first time in over 1
million years in the description section
of the file he wrote only one thing reap
what you seow then it was time to try a
new cycle to begin a new in the year
2022 the SCP Foundation was planning a
full exploration attempt of an anomaly
known as SCP
001a SCP 001 daa was a shipping
container the exterior of which was
reinforced with an unknown substance SCP
001 A-1 was a flat metallic device
serving as the container's cockpit SCP
001 a-2 were 57 identical humanoid
entities of indeterminant gender or
identity dressed in blue jumpsuits with
the words project Beluga emblazoned on
them all entities were found in and
around the cockpit they were all notably
hostile and would attempt to attack
investigators when the cockpit was
opened it revealed SCP 001 d-3 an
extradimensional space that consisted
mainly of interior corridors for a
fortified storage area on September 1st
2022 the speaker system of SCP 001 D's
internal console began to loudly
broadcast a concerning announcement
first it began with emergency emergency
emergency followed by the mimetic
passphrase that could only be spoken by
a current or former
05-11 without the subject immediately
bursting into flames the announcement
continued likelihood of ganam protocol
enactment if non-action is taken
approximately 100% XK SK ZK YK class
scenario all pending I am stranded on
the the 50th basement level of SCP 001
a-3 there are possibly several children
down here with me this message will
repeat until my demands are met help me
emergency emergency emergency site
director nay Smith and the 05 Council
were both consulted on the matter and
researcher Aaron gutii was chosen to
meet with whoever was responsible for
the distress call he had recently been
exposed to a faf near class infohazard
and was scheduled for termination
sometime soon anyway so he decided to
use his dying hours productively he was
equipped with a hidden microphone and
sent to speak with the broadcaster while
Ty entered SCP 001 a-3 descending to
level B15 he took 15 steps into the
spacious area calling out for an answer
from whoever called for help at first
there was no response while tier began
to grow impatient saying look no one
upstairs believes this broadcast of
yours but we all agreed it's too weird
to not come down and at least hear you
out so what the H do you want again no
response irritated gual tiri turned to
leave but as he did the blast door slam
shut trapping him inside he could hear
the sound of heavy machinery moving
toward him he was suddenly confronted by
the sight of an autonomous weapon a
massive mechanized structure equipped
with drills and saws he screamed at the
sight hello it spoke my name is Dr
Lawrence Mel you going to follow my
demands scream if you agree the drills
word closed to guti's face screamed this
monster apparently what remained of Dr
maau demanded to know his name gutii
demanded to know what the entity wanted
from him maow repeated the request for
his name while Ty relented introducing
himself before asking why he was called
down here maal had a question of his own
response have you ever hated someone
non-stop for
9,492 687 years like most human beings
would in that scenario gualter answered
no moud snapped if not you have nothing
to say to me Maring responses to queries
and demands because we are not in the
same head space and only similar minds
are worthy of my friendship and tea time
now then onto business I need a minimum
of 20 homonid replicators fromp 2000 and
a cart blanch access to SCP 319 this is
for the sake of Humanity's future in the
year
2588 if these demands are not met then
in tus 60 seconds you are going to bang
on the gates of hell and beg the
stewards of Eternal damnation to give
you Sanctuary gualter offered a bargain
I I just want to know why you're doing
this this is too weird to be left open
call it a scientist's Instinct just tell
me that and I'll pull all my strings
topside and get you whatever you want I
swear cross my heart maau agreed to
these terms and used SC CP yez to
briefly share Consciousness with
gualtieri everything maau experienced
with ubu everything about project Beluga
all of those Millennia of suffering were
transferred into guti's head like a
vivid dream he saw the initial
manifestation of ubu in Greenland the
waking nightmare that followed macau's
own harrowing encounter with the Beast
its Twisted bathtime song his discovery
of potential salvation only to have his
hopes dashed by failed cycle after
failed cycle it was all the answers he
could have ever wanted and plenty he
never ever would have wished to know but
before gualtieri could hold up his side
of the bargain he promptly dropped to
the ground Dead maau made a note of this
unfavorable result running logic sub
routines confirm there is a non-zero
chance that this delivery is the
indirect work of ubu formulating
additional cation procedures to minimize
mental duris after his death gualter
arrived in Corbin the plane of existence
that acts as a form of afterlife and as
a home of the three moons initiative
there he was retrieved by several agents
of the initiative who spoke with him
about his experience just before his
death shaken up he told the agents what
he learned about SCP ubu and the
impending doom that the Earth was facing
much to his surprise they were not
phased by his descriptions of the Beast
of its appetite for violence and
unnatural abilities in fact they had
seen beasts like it before they knew
exactly what SCP ubu was and they knew
exactly how to stop it for good boom on
May 12th 2588 the town of Kangas
Greenland was destroyed by a devastating
4 kiloton explosion accompanied by a
massive electromagnetic pulse the few
survivors that made it through the
incident alive described seeing a pale
green light in the area at the time of
the explosion shortly after an omka
class scenario or end of death scenario
began in which all multicellular life on
Earth began to experience a regenerative
effect regardless of injury or illness
in other words nobody could die anymore
this resulted in intense worldwide panic
in the face of the inexplicable
occurrence as the Panic mounted the 05
Council of the FCP Foundation held an
emergency meeting in order to address
the possibilities at hand meanwhile
civilians began reporting sightings of a
gigantic pale white humanoid monster
rampaging through their cities and
communities wrecking havoc and violently
attacking anyone and anything in its
path as the situation progressed and
worsened and the reality of the end of
death scenario began to set in the SCP
Foundation made the difficult decision
to lift its veil of secrecy and reveal
itself to the world
05-18 further instructions 5 days after
the world learned the truth of the SCP
Foundation the pale monster arrived in
St John's New Finland where it was met
by mobile task force new7 hammerdown for
what they hoped would be quick fight and
neutralization instead 2 years of
devastating bloody combat ensued by July
4th 2590 90% of the Task Force personnel
had been killed and regenerated an
average of five times at this point MTF
new7 abandoned the city of St John
citing anomalously poor working
conditions after being held in place for
2 years the monster was able to break
through the defensive line and continue
its Rampage on October 10th 2590 the SCP
Foundation and the global occult
Coalition came together in an act of
unprecedented cooperation to found
project Beluga dedicated to the goal of
neutralizing the monster designated SCP
ubu and stopping its reign of terror but
project Beluga was unable to neutralize
the entity before it reached Columbus
Ohio on December 29th 2590 once it
arrived in the city SCP ubu began
dedicating its time to a gruesome
personal project first it dug a 2 km
deep hole in the city's Center next it
gathered a total of 2.9 Million
civilians throwing them into the hole
after the hole was full The Entity
leaped into the upper Stratosphere over
and over again stomping into the hole
each time when the people inside were
pulverized The Entity destroyed a large
Fountain which it used as a cup and
drank the resulting juices from the hole
this entire process took roughly one
year and when it was finished the entity
appeared to grow bored with Columbus and
move to Lake Erie upon reaching Lake
Erie SCP ubu trudged out into the water
and began assaulting the cargo ship
stock there it began lifting ships up
and throwing them out of the water some
flying high enough to exit Earth's
gravitational pole altogether two of the
ships were later spotted on the surface
of the Moon this chaos and destruction
continued for years and years until June
10th 26 70 when SCP ubu was contained at
SCP Foundation site 59 however this
containment only lasted for 2 minutes at
which point The Entity escaped and made
its way to New York City where it was
found howling and attempted to defile
the Statue of Liberty several countries
used their nuclear arsenals to attack
SCP ubu over the course of its Rampage
until this connecti agreement was signed
on February 10th
2674 cementing an agreement between NATO
Powers the Russian Federation the
People's Republic of China and the
global occult Coalition all signatories
agreed that due to concerns around the
environment any additional nuclear
strikes against the entity would be
prohibited after the signing was
finished SCP ubu crashed the ceremony
grabbing several lengths of rebar and 15
foreign dignitaries which it used to
construct itself a bead necklace the
next notable incident occurred when SCP
ubu showed up at site 19 interrupting a
round of testing with SCP AF a woman
capable of turning matter into stone by
speaking to it SCP ubu broke through the
ceiling crushing AFF beneath its weight
SCP 682 which was also present
approached the entity curiously and SCP
ubu responded by angrily defecating and
shouting at SCP 682 in gibberish SCP 682
seemed to understand this vocalization
and attacked SCP ubu demanding that it
take back the insult at this point SCP
ubu slapped 682s cheek causing 682 to
let out a horrific Scream the slap left
behind a glowing green Mark which spread
over the entity of 682s body before
breaking the bonds of its cells all at
once dissolving the reptile into a pool
of toxic fluid SCP ubu then spent 5
minutes bathing in this fluid while
giggling after finishing its bath
devouring the reconstituted SCP and
screaming into the microphone for 20
minutes SC CP ubu broke into armed
containment area 179 and swallowed SCP
2317 hole on March 5th 2686 SCP ubu
conducted an assault on Thal class SCP
2000 rendering it neutralized again
years of Hell passed as project Beluga
struggled to come up with new methods
that had not already been exhausted
meanwhile civilians did their best to
find ways to cope with the state of the
world on March 25th 2750 former film
star Nash deg grut published the zon
Manifesto A book based around a simple
principle life on Earth was no longer
worth living consciously and the only
way formed was to enter an eternal coma
through the combination of chemicals and
guided meditation this kick started the
social movement the international zon on
June 24th 2790 project Beluga forces
managed to drive SCP ubu into the Bay of
Bengal where remained for 3 years
causing very little trouble side from
underwater seismic events meanwhile the
international Zone continued to grow and
one massive adherence known as cutopia
reached its goal of 5 million residents
on June 10th
2793 SCP ubu flung SCP 3,000 out of the
ocean leaving it beached on the soil of
India several cities were destroyed in
this process The Entity then spent a
week pointing and laughing at The
Beached sea monster before grabbing it
by the tip of its tail and beginning to
drag it across Asia SCP ubu continued
carving a path through Asia the
wriggling SCP 3000 in tow until it
reached the bearing straight then it
began to cross the straight into Alaska
returning to North American territory
once more but it didn't stopped there
instead advancing toward South America
until it and SCP 3000 arrived on the
eastern coast of Brazil on August 29th
2793 there it dragged its unfortunate
charge back into the ocean once more
disappearing from sight on August 30th
2793 SCP 169 or the Leviathan emerged
from the depths of the ocean there are
some reports that SCP 3000 had been tied
around its neck but these have not been
confirmed the Leviathan and SCP ubu then
entered into a lengthy battle which
carried on for several hundred years
after so much time had passed that
Witnesses could scarcely remember a time
when it wasn't happening the fight
between SCP ubu and SCP 169 came to a
halt much as it had with SCP 682 SCP ubu
slapped SCP 169 across the face with
such force that its cell bonds dissolved
and it melted into a puddle of fluid
which was lost beneath the ocean waves
SCP 169 was reclassified neutralized
December 11th 320 marked the start of a
10-year period of inactivity for SCP ubu
ordinarily one would expect this to come
with a sense of relief however even in
spite of the global immortality the
collateral damage from SCP ubu's
centuries of Carnage had rendered the
surface of the Earth uninhabitable with
all land now underwater the remains of
human civilization persist on a single
archipelago of floating cities
constructed from ships and debris
meanwhile the international zon movement
has persisted gaining more and more
traction and popularity as conscious
life became less and less bar
an enormous floating zon pile consisting
of international zon followers using
anomalous methods to achieve the perfect
zon began to form eventually this pile
earned the nickname new zland by May
28th 3028 the archipelago was abandoned
and the 140 remaining conscious humans
retreated to the SCP foundation's scps
nasmith there they lived in relative
safety for several months until SCP ubu
was spotted in the water off the port
bow of the N on January 14th 3030 it
emitted several sounds that Witnesses
described as mocking before swimming off
towards new zlin in response to this
reappearance after 10 years of
inactivity the 05 Council called an
emergency meeting the transcript for
this meeting reads as follows we haven't
exhausted all of our anomolous options
for neutralizing ubu where's the corn
crake we've been overse sorence sing the
Kong cake in this mess is only going to
it is anchored 57 clicks due Southeast
for while why the hell did you tell him
that well friends it seems the Omega K
has had us up in about so long that our
personalities have run out of fuel we
were given from birth in all likelihood
we'd see better professionalism and
teamwork in new zland as a matter of
fact that's a good segue into what I was
about to propose and frankly I hope you
find the nicest cleanest spots in the
mass grave where are you going that
depends which way is southeast at this
point 05-11 left the room presumably to
track down the corn CR leaving the
remains of the 05 Council there and
leaving the remains of project Beluga
with the question of how to handle SCP
ubu according to its official SCP
Foundation file SCP ubu is an extremely
violent and hostile humanoid entity of
Unknown Origin which appeared in
Greenland on May 12th 2588 it displays
anomalous physical strength and speed as
well as reality bending capabilities and
the emission of regenerative Lambda
waves linked to the ongoing end of death
scenario the appearance of SCP ubu and
the start of the end of death scenario
coincided with several additional
phenomenon there was a mass loss of
function for all the objects operated by
the three moons initiative the three
moons initiative was an extradimensional
human organization based in SCP
2922 C or the afterlife known as
corbenic this organization was founded
14,000 years ago with the purpose of
establishing a human colony in the the
afterlife and has long maintained a
peace treaty with the SCP Foundation SCP
2922 a method of communication that
allowed a human mind to make calls to
any pre-established phone number ceased
all functions next the extradimensional
space known as The Wanderer Library a
magical Archive of all the knowledge
from all known worlds and every book
that has ever been written will be
written and several that have not and
will not exist was severed from Earth
when the SCP Foundation pressed the
Serpent's hand for answers a
representative answered that
irreconcilable security concerns
regarding Earth had come up and forced
them to make this decision a
representative of Marshall Carter and
dark limited somehow gained access to
the personal contact information of the
05 council's members and use this
information to reach out to them with a
business offer the company is ordinarily
on unfriendly terms with the SCP
Foundation due to their conflicting
interests namely Marshall Carter and
dark's interests in acquiring Ing and
selling anomalous items entities and
experiences to the highest bidder
however in this case the company's
representative approached 05 council
members with a mixture of politeness and
Desperation begging the SCP Foundation
to purchase large amounts of the
company's stock the forest known as SCP
4000 lost all of its anomalous
properties all at once investigation
revealed only a small parchment note in
the area's entryway which read good luck
one of the most perplexing and discon
erting phenomenon that occurred
concurrently with SCP ubu's first
appearance was what happened to SCP 3
2008 the infinite Ikea though this sort
of thing should have been impossible the
infinite Ikea was anomalously purchased
by some unknown entity the Ika branding
was stricken from the building and it
was converted into an emergency shelter
all of these occurrences combined to
serve as a warning something big is
coming and indeed it was scpu U it
appears to be impervious to most forms
of damage including blunt force trauma
heavy caliber machine gun fire
temperatures up to 1600° Kelvin
artillery fire and Direct Energy
discharge from other anomalies it did
express some discomfort when exposed to
severe simultaneous direct nuclear
strikes but it was not affected beyond
that the only recorded instance of
lasting damage to SCP ubu was on August
14th 2784 in which the entity bit its
left thumb seemingly for no reason other
than curiosity after biting its thumb
The Entity scream for 7 days straight
then entered into a month-long crying
fit 30 years and 14 days later the thumb
had completely healed SCP ubu stands at
a height of 4.3 M while an exact measure
of its weight is unknown attempts at
measurement during its brief time in
containment showed that its weight is at
least
15399 kg its exact anatomical
composition is unknown but a superficial
examination of the entity indicates that
its body shape resembles that of a large
androgenous humanoid covered in hairless
white skin similar in texture to that of
a dolphin or small whale The Entity has
no eyes ears or nostrils but seems to
still possess the ability to see hear
and smell its only visible sensory organ
aside from its skin is its5 M wide mouth
humanoid in nature with a prehensile
tongue of unknown length on its lower
body it has no apparent features aside
from a kowa that it uses to dispose of
waste SCP ubu is prone to vocalizations
mainly screaming laughing and babbling
but it does not appear to understand
speech in any known language nor does it
seem to be attempting to communicate
with anyone it encounters its primary
interest appears to be destruction and
causing as much of it as possible it
will attack anything that it can get its
hands on but seems to show a particular
preference for attacking and consuming
human beings in large populous areas
such as cities its demeanor is both
sadistic and childlike and it has been
seen playing with its victims for hours
before moving on to a new Target due to
its regenerative effect present in SCP
ubu's vicinity it is incapable of
causing permanent damage to any living
thing and seems to have no greater
motivation Beyond causing fear and pain
SCP ubu is classified as Tiamat meaning
that it cannot be reasonably contained
at this time with the sources that the
foundation has therefore the focus has
shifted from containment to
neutralization which is ongoing via
project Beluga any and all non-critical
resources will be funneled into project
Beluga as neutralization of SCP ubu is a
top priority additional information on
neutralization efforts is restricted and
may only be accessed by members of
project Beluga but in the end it won't
be project Beluga that defeats this
monstrous creature it'll be the staunch
efforts of one extremely dedicated
researcher on May 12th 2588 The Entity
known as SCP ubu manifested in Kangas
Greenland like something out of the most
nightmarish Kaiju movie never made soon
after there was no more death but the
world was filled with such chaos and
despair that Humanity longed for that
Eternal release from its enormous
stomping feet to its cloa to its face
featureless save for a gaping grinning
devouring mouth The Entity was pure
malice with all the time in the world
ubu decimated the planet breaking the
spirit of mankind and raising every city
to the ground in the earlier days of
ubu's invasion when there was still dry
land and people still wanted to talk to
each other rather than joining floating
islands of Eternal chemically induced
Slumber they would commiserate about the
shared misery of the state of things oh
ubu my daughter hasn't spoken to me ever
since that monster shoved my whole body
down her throat someone would say
another would pipe up up trying to one
up the first man in sort of a trauma
Olympics didn't you see me in the news
ubu carried me around for a week
snacking on me every now and then like I
was his own personal Turkey Leg it was
hell but honestly part of me felt a
little bummed out when he threw me away
yet another person would chime in like
veterans swapping War Stories over a
drink at the bar ubu made me eat a pair
of my pants whole thing zipper and all
then he decided he thought that was
funny made me eat pair after pair after
pair of them rinse and repeat by the
time he got bored i' had eaten probably
around 20 paars and sort of got a taste
for them after that everyone on the
planet had good reason to despise
scpu but no one held more hate in his
heart for the pale Wicked creature than
Dr Lawrence moud before the world was
turned upside down sometimes literally
Dr moud was a member of the mysterious
05 council at the SCP Foundation to be
specific he was
05-11 but that prestigious position I at
the foundation couldn't protect him or
his loved ones from the wrath of ubu
when Dr moud was off duty ubu attacked
him and his wife first it impaled his
wife on a broom handle next it threw Dr
moud into an open pool of sewage in the
street then it bathed him in the filthy
water using his screaming wife as a
scrubbing brush all the while whistling
a horrible little bathtub song Centuries
after that awful experience as Dr maoud
watched most of his colleagues give up
and choose the closest thing to death in
this broken world he became even more
determined to do something about it on
January 14th 3030 Dr moud abandoned the
scps naysmith and his fellow 05 council
members in search of the scps Corn crate
and abandoned craft to the southeast it
wasn't an easy Journey rowing all the
way there in a Lifeboat never knowing
when the Great White Beast would emerge
from the water and choose him as its
next unfortunate play thing he could see
the scps corn cek still floating there
untouched but before he could row any
closer something collided with the
Lifeboat From Below snapping it in half
Dr macau's stomach dropped at the sight
of pale flesh but it was soon replaced
with relief when he saw that the thing
that had broken his Lifeboat was not in
fact ubu it was an injured narwhal
behaving erratically due to its runs the
culprit was almost certainly ubu it
wasn't content to just torment humans
but instead must have been targeting any
life form that could feel pain and fear
in his own words Dr moud had put it at
least a mass extinction wouldn't have
made it that personal after the life
boat broke apart moud swam to the conre
exhaustion and cold straining his
muscles it took him 2 hours to reach the
abandoned cargo barge and containment
site but eventually he managed to climb
up over the side and get on board there
was one very special thing about the
corn crate the thing that made it worth
crossing the ocean in in a fragile
little Lifeboat to find every anomaly
that made the gamed list the list of
anomalies considered too dangerous to
abandon even in an apocalyptic scenario
was contained on the corn crake if there
was anything left that the foundation or
anyone else hadn't tried to use to
defeat ubu it would be on that ship
after taking a little while to recover
Dr moud embarked on an initial
exploration of The Craft all the staff
were gone as he had expected thankfully
he still had his 05 ID card and it still
worked like a charm unlocking all of the
automated security systems on board a
lot of what he found was in Ruins but
some things had survived he found 10
hominid replicators from SCP 2000 in
perfect working order there was a cage
containing the remains of SCP 2845 the
deer though ubu had done significant
damage to it SCP 319 a curious device
was there contained in the space locked
vacuum chamber this one was notable for
its potential ability to destroy the
universe he found a couple of safe class
anomalies such as SCP yez crowd control
for the Practical Optimist and SCP FNA
the portable warehouse the latter of the
two was a portable door frame to a
pocket Dimension he also stumbled upon
SCP 001 Last Ride of the day an old
promethus Labs prototype of a time
machine and possibly most importantly he
found s CP
076 the coffin was open but Abel didn't
attack Dr maoud he wasn't consumed with
murderous rage and blood lust the way he
always was before instead he was just
sitting on the edge of the ship silently
staring at the sea when he spotted moud
he gave him a small wave and did nothing
else the centuries of a world without
death a world without killing without
victory in battle had taken its toll on
him for possibly the first time in his
eternal life Abel was depressed n days
after he first inspected the corn CR mik
began to formulate a plan he loaded all
the homed receptors into SCP FNA using a
thankfully still working forklift next
he was able to unseal the sealed portion
of SCP 001 Last Ride of the day and get
his hands on the details of the anomaly
it read SCP 001 is capable of temporally
relocating to its relative position
15,000 years prior to activation
this temporal displacement is Divergent
Paradox Irrelevant in other words a
separate timeline is created as a
landing point for example if an occupant
from timeline X were to murder their
parents in utero in Timeline y the Y
iteration of the occupant would no
longer exist but the occupant themselves
being from X would be unharmed when in a
fully active State SCP 001 deploys a 5 m
High telescopic antenna that functions
as a coloo wave energy energ sync
essentially Colo waves could only be
produced as a byproduct of the universe
suddenly being exterminated and ZK class
reality failures produced the most Colo
waves in one of these scenarios as CP
001 would be able to use these waves to
go back in time 15,000 years effectively
resetting reality to a point far before
the catastrophe happened this
information allowed him to put his plan
together to resurrect project Beluga
step one explosive charges around SCP
319 step two hide anything potentially
useful against SCP ubu inside of SCP FNA
step three get into the cockpit with SCP
FNA in toe step four raise the Colo sink
and step five blow the whole thing up 3
days later it was time to put the plan
into motion Dr mcow placed the charges
around SCP 319s vacuum chamber there was
enough in place to implode the walls of
the vacuum chamber he closed the
bulkhead and began deploying the Colo
sync 10% 25% 30% suddenly he could hear
a loud crashing sound the ship began to
tilt oh no he could hear the distant
sound of menacing Giggles the sync
reached 45 57 but as ubu grew closer he
quickly overrode the system to lower the
sink 45% 30% 25% 10% ubu grew closer and
closer and as it approached it began to
whistle the tune it once used when it
bathed moud and his wife in the sewer
ubu began to pound against the blast
door becoming increasingly frustrated as
it struggled to break through suddenly
another voice cut through the air an
unexpected one SCP 076 AEL called out to
maod encouraging him to carry on while
Abel held the Beast back as Abel and ubu
engaged in an epic battle maoud suddenly
remembered something there was an
Express deployment module for the kico
syn with no time to waste waste he
activated it all at once he hit the
Detonator and then the year was
11,970 and the date was February 14th
13,960 years later the SCP Foundation
discovered something beneath a mound of
Earth and snow near the northern border
of Lapland Finland it was a shipping
container with a reinforced exterior the
interior of which could only be accessed
through a fortified bulkhead on one side
the words SCP 001 were written on the
side in Black paintt in spite of this
the object was given the designation as
CP 848 a narrow winding tunnel through
the mound of Earth and snow was
discovered leading from the door to the
outside world the tunnel had significant
wear clearly having been used as a footp
path by someone but who well on April
12th 1993 the foundation got their
answer SCP 88848 bulkhead opened and a
man stepped out snapping his fingers and
promptly sealing the door behind him he
was designated pole 8048 he was a
32-year-old man of French Canadian
descent answering to the name of doct
Lawrence moud he made a series of claims
that the foundation found dubious but
noted it in the official file for SCP
8848 just the same these included but
were not limited to SCP 8848 is a time
machine he held the office of 05-11 in
the year 3030 from an alternate timeline
said timeline experienced a modified
Omega K Class end of death scenario that
coincided with the invasion of a tiok
class anomaly known as SCP ubu SCP ubu
was an extremely dangerous and sadistic
entity who was capable of among other
things neutralizing SCP 169 and SCP 682
his timelines version of the foundation
launched project Beluga which resulted
in an impossible war with SCP ubu that
lasted 441 years Paul 848 deliberately
sabotaged SCP 319 to act as a power
source for SCP 8848 thus arriving in
Lapland in the year
11,970 BCE SCP ubu will arrive in
Greenland on May 12th
2588 Paul 848 was able to extend his
lifespan by sharing his Consciousness
between a Central Computer within SCP
8848 and several thousand bodies created
by his personal hominid replicators said
Consciousness sharing was achieved
through a book classified in the future
as SCP yez he wishes to assist the
foundation in the termination of SCP ubu
and has laid out a plan for its
termination as outlined in document
848-4000 data points known only to
members of the 05 Council the foundation
was forced to take him at least a little
bit seriously a motion was filed
requesting that poll 8048 be allowed to
to assist the foundation with the
termination of SCP ubu as per document
848 Zeta 054 voted yay 0 5-7 abstained
and the rest of the council voted nay
the motion failed to pass a follow-up
motion was filed in response requesting
that poll 8048 be allowed to assist the
foundation with their own strategy to
respond to SCP ubu 05-10 5-4 057 and
05-10 abstained from voting the rest
vote voted nay the motion failed to pass
on April 14th 1995 Dr Isaiah Henderson
and Paul 848 sat down for an interview
when asked to State his name Dr Macau
also recited a mimic passphrase that
when spoken by anyone other than 05-11
of past or present would cause them to
burst into flames the two men were at
odds from the beginning Dr Macau
expressed dismay and frustration that
his proposal was rejected meanwhile Dr
Henderson countered with the insistence
that macau's proposed plan was rejected
for posing an unnecessary risk to the
civilian public they debated for a
moment before Dr Henderson announced the
foundation's next plan of action Dr moud
was to be terminated the foundation
would proceed with its plans without him
at that point Dr Henderson terminated
moud as ordered he didn't count on one
thing though moud was no longer an
ordinary man bound to one body he hopped
into the body of a guard then into the
body of 054 to deliver a vital message
he had started this plan alone and was
ready to bring it to a close alone
project Beluga would continue with or
without the foundation support Dr Macau
returned to the bulkhead climbing back
inside and sealing it behind him he had
hoped to have the foundation behind him
he had hoped they would be allies in the
fight against the greatest evil mankind
ever encountered but they disappointed
him he had waited thousands of years
only for the organization he devoted his
life to to try and kill him well he
wasn't going to go down without a fight
this was bigger than the foundation
bigger than anyone and no living person
was as equipped to handle ubu as he was
so he resumed project Beluga as a
one-man operation he issued a mission
statement which read as follows on May
12th 2588 The Entity known as SCP ubu
invaded and pillaged human civilization
for no other motivation than cruelty and
selfish gratification shortly thereafter
project Beluga was founded as a joint
eff between the goblo cult Coalition and
the SCP Foundation for the purposes of
ubu's Destruction ubu is not merely a
threat to human safety he's an a front
to every positive and loving Concept in
the human consciousness rather than our
lives he seeks to destroy our quality of
life to State his own sick desires think
about it the taste of ice cream playing
with your dog the way you felt after
your first kiss that is ubu's sworn
Enemy No fate is too cool for him no
hatred is strong enough when project
Beluga Charter was signed 592 GOC
officers and Foundation staff were
present at the ceremony our troops
numbered in the hundreds of thousands I
Dr Lin mik am the only surviving member
and always will be what I lack in
numbers is compensated thousandfold by
my weapons my mind my replicated bodies
and the ons of experience the following
record serves one purpose alone that
once justice has been brought to you U
humans in The Shining and golden ubu
free future will understand that one
person can accomplish through the power
of hard science and raw emotion entwined
in a perfect and indestructible braid
and while we are at it you are very
welcome over the next several hundred
years moud worked to secure ownership of
kusto Greenland through a project Beluga
civilian front he evacuated the civilian
population from the area then spent a
century constructing a super weapon with
100 high yield nuclear weapons heat
amplification runes a targeting Beacon
for SCP dag and five antimatter
Gathering pods from SCP H&M in place he
was finally ready for ubu to manifest
again Sun's gone bad people and animals
are melting everywhere the world is
coming to an end and there's nothing I
can do about it will I'll be able to
find food will I'll be able to defeat or
avoid the horrific flesh monsters all
around me or the desperate and hungry
survivors left in this terrible New
World keep watching and find doubt can I
survive 100 days in SCP 001 when day
breaks hey folks it's your boy Kyle you
probably know me more for gaming videos
than post apocalyptic Vlogs but hey I'm
a versatile guy and I think I might go
insane from the fear if I don't talk to
somebody about all this craziness if
you're live and seeing this right now
well congratulations you're probably
doing a lot better than most people here
if you call them people now but if
you're seeing this a few years in the
future like I don't know you woke up
from a 10-year con like Rick from The
Walking Dead and you're wondering what
the hell happened to planet Earth this
video is probably going to answer a lot
of your questions first things first
whatever you do you've got to stay away
from the Sun it touches you for even a
second you're dead or Worse welcome to
day one of the end of the world for all
of you who are still in a solid state of
matter you're probably wondering how I'm
still alive too chances are it's for the
exact same reason you are sheer dumb
luck I was down here my gaming basement
when day broke just level grinding when
my TV got taken over by those SCP
Foundation people telling us that the
sun's gone evil for whatever reason and
now we've all got to stay inside hell if
I was up there making myself a sandwich
or grabbing another can of Mountain Dew
I'd be a freaking puddle right now it's
funny my mom always told me spending all
day indoors was bad for me I'll have to
mention that to her if she's alive point
is the world has gone to Hell in a hand
basket and now I've got only one
objective survive I'm going to see if I
can survive the horrifying
post-apocalyptic world of when day
breaks for this first day I'm just going
to hunker down I kind of hope this is
just a dream day two all right I'm up
and atam baby sadly I can now report
that this isn't a dream this really is
our horrible new reality it's the sun's
world and we're just living in it I've
been spending the last several hours
just waiting for Nightfall outside
Against All Odds the internet and the
power grid haven't gone down yet guess
what's ever wrong with with the sun only
affects people and animals not objects
thank heaven for small mercies right
people on Twitter have been live posting
their situations out there sharing
advice on how we might all be able to
stay out of the Sun and survive this
whole crazy thing and hey unless they're
dead or full of hot air maybe those SCP
Foundation people know something about
what's going on here if we really can
get to their buildings maybe we can
figure out how to reverse all this mess
maybe for now I'm just going to focus on
staying alive hopefully Night hits soon
I really need to use the bathroom oh boy
it's day three and new issues are
starting to pop up I've been heading
upstairs to go to the bathroom but while
I don't want to be crude I'm running low
on toilet paper and it's um starting to
become a problem I ran out of my last
roll a few days ago and now I'm starting
to go to my bookshelves I have a few
newspapers left that I tore up and used
for toilet paper first um they weren't
exactly comfortable but hey you need to
make do but without toilet paper and
without newspapers I need to figure out
what my favorite and least favorite
books are I'm starting with the prefaces
of all the books seeing as I don't
generally need to reread them you know
they're Expendable you know a lot of
these books I haven't read since I was
like 15 so maybe those will be the ones
I can't make up my mind on whether I'm
going to use the Harry Potter books or
the Percy Jackson and The Olympian books
first uh let me know what you think in
the comments I guess I need to go to the
bathroom day four and now I'm trying to
figure out how to pass the time as you
already know I'm an AOW lifelong gamer
so while the electricity and the
internet still work I'm going to keep
gaming to pass the time and keep my all
to Precious sanity I still have no
intention of going out there even at
night but it's left me feeling kind of
stir crazy I want to walk around the
city again I want to go for a drive and
feel the breeze in my hair but seeing as
I can't do that without experiencing a
truly horrifying transformation I've
been spending a lot of time on GTA 5
online guess we'll never get GTA 6 now
what a bummer still these last few days
it's felt more like Los Santos has been
my home than where I actually live there
were even a few other people on the
server I don't know about you but I take
some comfort in that hey folks I'm back
thankfully welcome to day five we've
still got electricity thankfully hence
why you can still see this I haven't
heard anything from my family and I
don't want to assume the worst but yeah
it's probably just best not to think
about it I've been heading up and
downstairs to grab more food at night
you're probably wondering but Kyle why
don't you bring it all downstairs to
save going up altogether which I'd say I
don't have a fridge downstairs smartass
but I'm starting to realize food is
going to be a real issue here it's kind
of stupid now that I think about it in
all the zombie movies and TV shows I
used to watch it was all bullets and
baseball bats killing your way through
all the those Undead Freaks and worrying
about the rest later guess they don't
want you to think about how you're only
going to ever be a couple weeks away
from starvation kind of ruins the badass
post-apocalyptic power fantasy I only
have a couple days worth of food left
here and after that I'm going to need to
go out and search for more or I'm going
to need to relocate I don't feel
comfortable here anymore you know early
on I thought when you got exposed to the
sunlight it just killed you but no it's
worse you keep living you're just
changed into one of those things these
last few days I've looked out the
windows when I've come up at night for
food I I see them sometimes slithering
in the yard or down the street these
things that used to be people I wonder
if they people that I knew once before
all this and I tried to shove the
thought out of my mind freaking myself
out about all this doesn't help I know
that much just keep thinking about how
do they move this like weird kind of
purpose like they're searching for
something but what could they be
searching for I'm just going to go and
get more food we'll speak again soon
stay safe whever you are welcome to day
six it's night time now and I'm heading
out for the first time I keep seeing
these weird slimy creatures everywhere
and they make me kind of sick to look at
them but I try my best to just keep
moving I'm on a mission tonight I'm
going to go to local supermarket and
check to see if there's still food there
while also grabbing myself a quick snack
I'm going to keep this one brief I don't
want want to do a full shopping spree
tonight and it's already too late just
need to know the food is there I decided
earlier in the night if I survive this
thing and the getting is good at the
bargain Mark I'll make my way back
tomorrow for something a little more you
know substantial after all the fewer
trips I make out the safer I'm likely to
be by the time I made it to the
supermarket though while I was
practically a nervous wreck from the
fear of turning into one of those things
I made an amazing Discovery while the
windows were broken and the floor was a
mess most of the food was still there
day set
or should I say night 7 galvanized by My
Success from the previous days I decided
to come back to the supermarket with a
shopping cart I wanted to get enough
food for at least a week so I wouldn't
need to come back out again hey maybe
I'm not so bad at this whole apocalypse
thing after all I grabbed plenty of
canned food from the supermarket most of
the perishables had already gone moldy
by the time I showed up so fresh fruit
was out of the question suddenly I
started getting scared about the thought
of scurvy but pushed it quickly from my
mind I'd cross that bridge when I got to
it hey hey it's day eight and I'm still
kicking that's got to count for
something right I started taking more
trips out at night time just to stretch
my legs and keep the blood flowing when
the slithering things that were once
people past me I just make myself scarce
and hide in the shadows you know I I
hear them muttering sometimes and like
this melted Voice or voices it's
unsettling but it's amazing what you'll
get used to in just over a week it's e
to see all these streets without people
in them I know that I should probably
just stay inside but I I really can't I
don't know if this will ever just stop
and if it doesn't I I don't want to
spend my last days cooped up in my own
basement day nine you know there are
some benefits to being in the
post-apocalypse to ever so slightly
offset all the utterly crushing
downsides while during the day we're all
prisoners of the Sun in our own homes at
night we can do whatever the hell we
want I took a baseball bat I keep in my
closet and went to the local furniture
store I smashed up every single vase and
all the windows like one of those rage
rooms because cuz nobody could stop me
then afterwards I went straight to the
local computer and gaming store and took
all the Alienware tech I could
physically carry you know there's no
value in money anymore if you want
something you can just go and take it
every cloud has a silver lining day 10
more GTA 5 today I decided to get on my
headset and speak to a few others who
were still around and on the servers you
know it was so nice to speak to other
human beings for once they came from all
over the world and were dealing with the
same evil Sun Insanity as me you have no
idea how incredibly valuable it is to
find people to talk to in a time like
this the other players had plenty of
theories as to why all this had happened
some thought it was some kind of mutant
solar flare they remembered reading
about on some conspiracy form back in
the day others speculated it was the
result of some weapon created by the us
or Russian or Chinese military that gone
wrong one person said that maybe it was
a punishment from God like maybe on some
level we all deserved it you know things
got pretty quiet after that day 11 I've
been having the most terrible nightmares
lately it's probably just just a product
of all the stress I've been under lately
but in the nightmares I'm running down a
dark Street being chased by those flesh
creatures I'm moving fast but they're
moving way faster they're whispering to
me but I can't make out anything they're
saying this morning which is to say
evening I woke up screaming and drenched
in sweat I can't really explain why but
I feel like something terrible is going
to happen soon okay okay I'm alive
that's enough isn't it and if you're
watching this I assume you're live too
congratulations welcome to the nightmare
space between day 11 and day 27 sorry
that I haven't been in contact for so
long as you can see I'm not at home
anymore you couldn't pay me to go back
there not that money is worth anything
anymore A lot's happened since I last
made one of these and I wish I could
tell you any of it was good hell I wish
I could forget it all but the things
I've seen and heard I don't think
they're ever going to leave my head no
matter what I do I thought about making
another entry now and then but but I
always found a reason to put it off it's
remarkable how your other priorities
fall away when you're just thinking
about where your next meal is coming
from it just kind of puts everything
into perspective of course during my
travels I saw more of those freaks
slithering around sorry sorry I I know I
shouldn't call them that it's kind of a
coping mechanism you know it all gets a
lot harder when you have to think of
them as X people that's another thing
all these goofy zombie shows got wrong
it's a lot harder to separate what they
were from what they are now especially
when you know these were your friends
your neighbors your well I can't avoid
talking about it forever can I I stuffed
my backpack with whatever I could grab
and left my home two nights ago it
wasn't just because I was going stir
crazy back there though I admit that
didn't exactly help it was what happened
there I just came back from a food run
put most of it in the fridge then
retired back down into the basement to
enjoy a late night snack and do a little
gaming to keep myself sane I've been
doing everything I could to reverse my
circadian rhythms and sleep during the
day just so I could be fully operational
during the 12-hour period that going
outside wouldn't melt me but just like
all those stories they told us when we
were kids there are monsters out there
at night and they are looking for us
when I first heard the sound I was I
wondered if it was something in game or
maybe dripping from a leaky pipe but no
it was too close to be fake and too
viscous to be water that's when I looked
at the door and saw this awful pink
slime slithering its way underneath my
door it was one of those those things
those ex people trying to get in that'd
be bad enough but then it started
talking to me Kyle my darling why are
you all cooped up down here it isn't
healthy you ought to come outside
sweetie get some Son my
darling it was my mom well it used to be
guess she wanted to come over and visit
me NE L to say I got out of there and
I've got no intention of going back that
place is dead to me now I don't even
want to think about that voice ever
again both her and so not her so now I'm
on the move guess I'll speak to you
again when I stop stay safe out there
day 28 I decided it was best to make my
way out of town towards the fringes the
day first broke the people who were in
the most densely populated areas were
the first to go that's why I decided to
haul up in a gas station last night just
to avoid the Sun but during the night
people came not ex people actual people
they showed up in a jeep outside the
building refueled and then came in they
were wearing black Cobble together
outfits and hockey masks they were all
either carrying bats or axes too you can
probably understand while I didn't
decide to introduce myself when they
busted their way in I concealed myself
in a broom closet while they searched
around it was nerve shredding I'd never
been more thankful in my life when they
left day 29 coming up on a month of this
madness
after the incident at the gas station I
realized I needed some kind of Defense
it's not just the Sun and those
creatures I need to worry about just
like the old world people could be
dangerous here too that's why I snuck
into a gun store in the dead of night
some of it had been looted but much like
the supermarket near my house there was
plenty still here the walls were covered
in all manner of rifles shotguns and
even submachine guns Ard somewhere that
revolvers are more reliable and easy to
maintain than other types so since I'm a
gun novice I grabbed a revolver and
stuffed my Rockets with as many bullets
as I could carry let's hope I never have
to use any of them day 30 do I get to
call this a month of survival I mean if
we're talking February I'd be a month in
already what a horribly dubious honor
that is I saw something disgusting last
night and I thought I'd share it just to
get it off my mind last night as I was
moving through the Wilderness I saw a
group of other survivors gathered around
a campfire I remain scarce but approach
just to see what was going on still
carrying My Revolver just to be safe but
the people around the campfire were
eating something and when I saw what
they were eating I swear to God I almost
threw up they were chopping up one of
the ex people cooking the parts over the
fire and eating it day 31 a month by
anyone's definition ever since seeing
those others eating one of the ex people
I've had trouble eating even normal food
myself my stomach aches and my throat
burns God I feel so weak I keep laying
down and resting I know I need to eat
soon if I want to survive to day 32 but
every time I think about eating I think
about the gooey flesh of the ex people
sometimes I wish I hadn't survived this
long I'll eat soon I just need to sleep
first day 32 to 43 if you live this long
you really ought to be proud of yourself
I've seen thousands of those slimy ex
people and there's probably Millions
more out there oh maybe even billions if
we're being honest with ourselves here
am I just talk talking into the void
here is there even anyone else out there
who's human enough to watch this stuff
maybe I just need to keep thinking about
posterity on the off chance that the
world ever gets better and we reach
sometime where children are born again
and all this Fades from Human memory
you'll still have these stupid pointless
little videos to remember how awful all
this was that way at least I can make
myself believe this all had some kind of
I don't know point so what's happened
with me not much
still moving at night surviving hiding
in closets and underground parking
complexes during daylight down to uh my
last few cans so I'm hoping to hit a
supermarket soon God what a ridiculous
way to go Starving in this new world
with so many new interesting ways to die
with the ex people things have been a
little more eventful there used to be
one blob to a person but they've started
joining up that's the best way I can put
it things that used to be people and
animals are starting to melt together
getting bigger and bigger they've never
been aggressive but I think it's best to
stay out of their way whatever all this
is about I am StreetWise enough to know
that it can't be anything good I'll just
keep moving and I hope you can do the
same whoever the hell you are hopefully
the next time I check in with you it's
with better news than this day 44 I saw
a shootout on the road last night the
people who are left the ones who are
still indeed people are be becoming less
human something about situations like
this this sustained stress and pain and
hopelessness it weighs on you there are
no rules in the post-apocalypse the only
thing that can stop you from doing
anything is a Bullet to the Head five or
six people last night as afraid and
desperate and hungry as me gunned each
other down they did this for reasons I
will never understand even if I want it
to because there are no survivors Left
To Tell the tale what a funny world we
live in day 45
I sleep when I can it's surreal I
remember when I feared the dark and
loved bright sunny days even all this
time in I still don't think I'm used to
the switch being flipped I've been
having awful dreams again I'm still
running in them with a deep red sun
shining up in the sky being chased by a
mountain of Flesh the size of Mount
Everest it's swallowing up the city
behind me and it keeps getting closer no
matter how fast I go I just I I can't
escape it'll get me eventually something
terrible is going going to happen soon I
just know it a46 I shot a man today I
don't know if you survived I hope you
lived we encountered each other inside
an abandoned building I I think we
spooked each other and didn't have any
time to ask if we were friends or foes
we were too afraid either way we both
drew our weapons and I was faster than
he was when my revolver discharged and
he collapsed i' ran off Sun would come
up in a few hours and I just needed to
find another place to hide what the hell
have I become I don't know how things
could get any worse than this not to
self in the future don't even dare to
think how could things get any worse
because if I've learned anything since
this whole nightmare started that is
never a rhetorical question welcome to
the space between day 47 and day 64 if
you're still Al and watching this I am
so sorry so I've got good news and I've
got bad news I'll give you the good news
first I've seen more people people who
haven't been changed yet and the bad
news last time I saw them they were
being dragged out into the light kicking
and screaming in the tendrils of one of
those horrible flesh monsters I was
telling you about last time they've
gotten a lot bigger now and when I told
you they weren't aggressive well um yeah
I I spoke a little too soon I can't just
sleep during the day like I used to
these monsters and that's what they are
now they're monsters not people anymore
they Patrol they hunt they actively
enter buildings searching for hiding
places searching for people they can
drag out into the light I've seen it
with my own two eyes the second they're
out they'll just start melting and
fusing with the mass making it even
bigger adding another voice to the chor
and I hate myself cuz every time I've
seen it happen all I can think is thank
God that's not me God I wish I could do
something to help to save them but
that's not the world we live in the
second they touch the light it is all
already over I wouldn't be helping
anyone by adding My Flesh to one of
those things I don't want them using my
body to get to other people there's only
one thing I can do now keep moving at
night stay hidden get away from
population centers I've realized where I
need to go now I've still got a distant
memory of those broadcasts in the
earlier days of the event the SCP
Foundation I noted down coordinates to
the nearest facility they had on the
books and if I'm honest nearest is only
a relative term cuz at this rate it's
going to take me an an eternity to get
there but it'll be worth it in the end
when I get there it all be worth it if I
can at least get some answers at least
know why the world turned into this hell
those SCP folks seem better prepared for
this than anyone so even if they can fix
this they've at least got to have
answers right somebody needs to have
answers I really want to believe that
when the Sun goes down I'll start moving
again if you're watching this wish me
luck I don't have much food left I'll do
what I can yeah hey I realize I'm not
looking great right now but trust me you
should see the other guy day 65 to day
86 never thought I would make it this
far but hey life's just full of
surprises before you ask and I mean why
would you ask it's not like I can hear
you it wasn't one of the monsters that
did this to me it was another person
just like me desperate hungry afraid the
one difference between me and and them
was the fact that they had a handgun and
I didn't they asked for all the food I
had and when I wasn't exactly
forthcoming they decided to shoot me and
steal the last of my food while I lay
bleeding on the ground oh well okay
that's not entirely Fair they did leave
me with one protein bar which I had to
cave and eat a couple days ago since
then I've just been forging with little
food I can from Plants along the way
during my nighttime walks but it isn't
much and my wound is giving me grief I
sure hope they've got doctors at this
SCP Foundation or
otherwise ow I may be even more out of
luck than I thought here's the good news
for you since I know how much you love
that I'm not far off of the foundation
site now even in this state I'm probably
only a couple weeks away I think maybe I
can will myself to live that long at
least if I can get some answers just
before I die then I can be happy happy
and sometimes folks that's all you can
ask for final stretch let's hope I see
you again on the other end stay safe I'm
here I'm here the SCP Foundation on day
100 but I don't understand where is
everybody hello is anybody there God
damn it why is nobody here I I don't
understand they were meant to have the
answers they were meant to know what was
going on here but they're all gone too
it isn't fair it isn't fair is this it
is it all just over the end of the
freaking world as we know it it isn't
fair it isn't fair isn't fair wait are
those footsteps hello yes hello I'm over
here who's there oh my God what the hell
is that thing no no get away from me oh
God
disgusting what is the most dangerous
creature in the universe here on planet
Earth there are creatures that have
hardly evolved since prehistoric eras
like sharks crocodiles and snakes
perfect biological killing machines but
then again the animal kingdom is nothing
when compared to the Minaj array of
creatures contained by the SCP
Foundation so once again what is the
most dangerous creature in the universe
is it SCP 682 the damage regenerating
reptile with a hatred for all other
forms of life or is it the Scarlet king
or is the broken God more deserving of
that title Maybe maybe the answer still
lies elsewhere and thankfully there is
one SCP in the foundation's archives
that might not be the most dangerous
itself but teaches us a very important
lesson about what the most dangerous
entity truly is this is the story of SCP
001 the spiral path an important
distinction before we go any further SCP
001 doesn't refer to a single creature
object or entity but rather a collection
of various anom IES contained by the SCP
Foundation it is unclear why there are
multiple files collected under the
shared designation of SCP 001 some
believe these anomalies are some of the
earliest ever contained by the
foundation encountered before they
introduce their current numbering system
there is also the theory that this is
intentional misdirection that the
multiple SCP 001 files are an attempt by
the foundation to conceal secret
information about the true SCP
001 sharing the name SCP 001 include the
infamous affir mentioned Scarlet King a
powerful Aldrich being intent on ending
all creation another anomalous being
with similar levels of destructive power
is the gate Guardian believed to be an
angel standing at the entrance to the
Garden of Eden it too goes by the name
SCP 001 but for the purposes of this
video we will be using SCP 001 to refer
to something otherwise codenamed the
spiral path and while while it is not a
creature in and of itself SCP 001 does
yield one answer to that important
question what is the most dangerous
creature in the universe on paper SCP
001 does not seem to be much and it
certainly doesn't appear to be any sort
of threat as its nickname suggests the
spiral path is exactly that located deep
in a wooded area known only as sight
zero SCP 001 is a gravel path in the
shape of a spiral your first thought at
hearing that might be what could be so
important about a path if someone were
to find themselves walking along the
spiral path traveling clockwise around
the gravel then they will find that
nothing happens it's just a normal path
with slight inclines and declines as one
traverses it if one should walk
counterclockwise around it though then
they will begin to experience SCP 001's
first anomalous effect the path will
begin to to feel as if it is sloping
uphill getting steeper and steeper when
they reach the beginning of the path
again a person will still feel as if
they are walking endlessly uphill all
the while the path itself does not move
or change in form or altitude to put it
simply walking one way around SCP 001
causes it to behave normally walking the
other the path does not adhere to the
laws of physics you may well be thinking
is that all on a surface level the
spiral path does appear to just be an
unmoving low threat anomaly while it may
not be as aggressive or malicious as
some of the SCP foundation's rog's
Gallery it is still a spatial anomaly
that defies all ukian geometry that
might sound like small potatoes when
compared to everything the SCP
Foundation has faced over the years but
bear in mind if the spiral path is truly
SCP 001 and the very first anomaly that
the foundation learned of then a simple
path that ignores the ordinary laws of
space time would have been a major
Discovery in the organization's earliest
days but why would they still keep the
spiral path so heavily guarded all these
years later SCP 001 is kept behind a
maximum security fence that has been
constructed all the way around the
perimeter of site zero at all times the
SCP Foundation keeps no less than five
fully armed members of security
Personnel on site to keep watch over the
spiral path and to make sure that no one
approaches it who isn't authorized to
there is a small metal plaque too
bearing an unknown inscription on it
special containment procedures for SCP
001 state that this plaque is to be kept
in good condition and it should be
immediately reported if it shows any
signs of damage a foundation Physics
laboratory is also located nearby where
research staff tirelessly conducts
scientific tests on SCP 001 and its
anomalous properties so there's
definitely something more to the spiral
path than a simple stroll around it
would tell you attached to SCP 001's
file is an item referred to as document
00-05 written by high-ranking Foundation
researcher Dr Everett man any
prospective or new members of the 05
Council are required to read this
document and from the events it details
learn the truth not just about the truth
of the Spiral path but the truth about
the SCP Foundation itself Dr man begins
this file by explaining to the reader
that either he or one of the original
founders of the SCP Foundation must have
died and the person reading has been
appointed as a successor whether his
death was caused by an SCP an operative
from another anomalous organization like
the global occult Coalition or getting a
little close to the flame man states
that old age definitely wouldn't be what
killed him he writes we took care of
that didn't we whether he means that he
and the rest of the Old Guard are
somehow Immortal or just working for the
foundation would likely mean dying
before reaching old age is unclear but
Dr man's next statement is one that
changes the very way we view the
foundation and its entire purpose we
have never discovered an SCP in the
entire history of the foundation
according to document
0015 every instance of an anomalous
creature entity or object is entirely
staged he then goes on to describe Aaron
seagull A Gifted physicist that Dr man
regarded very highly I believe his name
would be there with Edison Einstein and
Hawking I knew him very well he was and
may still be my brother the pair
evidently shared a close personal
connection and it was seagull who first
discovered SCP 001 during a hike Aaron
stumbled upon the spiral path noticing
that no matter how far up hill he seemed
to travel his elevation never once
changed only for him to end up back at
the start of the path being a physicist
seagull quickly realized how this
unassuming gravel path did not conform
to ukian Geometry that it did not fit
within the laws of nature constructing a
small wooden Shack nearby Aaron seagull
began to study the properties of the
Spiral path equation after equation
hours spent examining every variable and
experimenting with his findings until
something unforeseen happened Aaron
created an SCP a key that had the innate
ability to open any lock nowadays that
same key is still in the foundation
possession under the designation SCP
005 slowly Aaron began to bring others
into the fold trusted colleagues and
other scientific Minds among them was of
course Dr Everett man who was still a
medical student at Harvard at the time
this Brain Trust a think tank composed
of only a select few they were the very
beginning the ones who founded the SCP
Foundation using their own fortunes and
funding from Thomas Carter the group
continued with SE experiments the
scientists had high hopes for what they
could achieve planning to change the
world for the better feeding the hungry
providing shelter to the homeless curing
the sick and even cheating death itself
in the beginning this Proto Foundation
started small their goals were Noble but
could not realistically be achieved
overnight they tried to make items that
would improve life such as a fountain of
youth a partially sentient Civil War
statue and an extremely bouncy ball
better known to the foundation today as
SCP 006 SCP 011 and SCP 018 respectively
but then this New Foundation began to
grow with more organization and a secret
facility and with that expansion came
emboldened scientists eager to change
the world the group began working on
human test subjects volunteers and
Drifters that soon became scps the
spiral path was not just a break in the
fabric of reality in a metaphorical
sense it referred to the spiraling path
the newly formed Foundation itself was
on every Discovery they made led to
another and that to another still until
things started to go wrong during the
continuing experiments Dr Man created
SCP 008 a deadly Zombie Plague capable
of infecting anyone with 100% lethality
more and more of the founders were so
invested in their projects that the
results were often nightmarish the
foundation needed help that came when
Thomas Carter showed their work to the
military in exchange for additional
funding and Personnel the SCP Foundation
expanded even further becoming an
international organization and bringing
in new researchers and staff in some
instances the founders would arrange for
the anomalies they had created to be
found by the new recruits other times
they would fabricate reports changing
the details of how things like SCP 008
or the Fountain of Youth were first
discovered anything the Founders said
was simply now a fact no one questioned
them even then problems still arose
founding members broke away from the SCP
Foundation some even creating Splinter
groups that would later become infamous
groups of Interest the foundation's
directive shifted now focusing on the
containment of anomalies as yet more
were created through darker means SCP
231 was taken from an orphanage Dr man
himself vivisected a small boy who then
became SCP 16 10 the flesh that hates
and there were more still Abel the blood
Pond and even the hard to destroy
reptile all of them were the creation of
the foundation itself but through it all
Dr man wrote he was never afraid of the
path that the foundation was on he was
never even afraid of all the monsters
and Abominations that he and the other
Founders had secretly created by
studying SCP 001 what truly scared him
were the anomalies the foundation didn't
create there were some that would just
appear in containment one day even if
they hadn't been there before they would
seem like they had always been there Dr
man closes document
0015 with the realization that he and
the other Founders simply were not in
control anymore the tale of Dr man and
the other founders of the SCP Foundation
is one of noble intentions that
ultimately became corrupted at first the
founders created scps that they hoped
would benefit Humanity but then came the
mistakes the accidents the monsters like
SCP 008 SCP 610 and even SCP
682 the foundation lied to the
governments and militaries of the world
claiming they'd found these scps not
created them and in return they received
funding and staff to expand allowing the
SCP Foundation to grow to become what it
is today Dr man posits that at this
point the foundation was no longer in
control but perhaps they never were and
all of this stems back from One Singular
starting point the spiral path it might
be impossible to truly know how many
anomalies and scps the foundation
created just from researching SCP 001
only the 05 Council will ever know
exactly how many of the founders
discoveries they themselves were
responsible for and now you know the
answer to what's the most most dangerous
creature in the universe its regular
people dabbling with something they
could never hope to fully understand
starting with the hope to change the
world only to create monsters that might
one day destroy it the military
helicopter sailed through the skies at a
steady Pace its destination somewhere in
Southwest Asia along one of the many
points where the legendary Euphrates and
Tigress rivers meet depending on the
outcome this mission may may have
changed the course of the SCP Foundation
and its activities forever or it might
do nothing at all such was often the way
when it came to dealing with the
unpredictable and the anomalous inside
the helicopter Dr Anton zarov was
practically rattling with nervous
excitement ever since he'd been assigned
to the 682 termination detail after
years of wasting away in an archival
desk job he'd seen the kind of anomalies
you wouldn't believe 173 that
nightmarish statue that snaps the necks
of anyone who dared to look away from it
811 the strange and also strangely
adorable swamp woman whose costic mucus
could reliably melt seemingly any
organic matter save of course 682 itself
and Dr zarov was particularly astonished
by the aftermath of the epic battle
between 096 and 682 which left both of
these indestructible monsters horribly
maimed but all of that it was nothing
compared to what they were going to
witness today Dr zarov muttered a prayer
to himself in frightened reverence Dr
cleff Who was sitting across from him
and the helicopter wasn't quite as wound
up like some action movie cliche made
manifest he sliced chunks from a plump
red apple with a Bowie knife and sucked
the pieces off the blade clef found
zarov nervousness little more than
amusing first time at sight zero rookie
CF asked between apple slices Dr zarov
nodded forcing a Meek smile klef just
chuckled you're wasting your time you
know klef said everyone takes a shot at
the reptile I face it down myself once
mono imano and during that moment I
realized something as much as it pains
me to ever throw in the towel we're not
going to kill this thing it's just a
budget sync of course these kinds of
doubts had crossed Dr zarov mind before
he'd watch countless termination
attempts organized by far more senior
researchers than himself fail and fail
embarrassingly something about about
signing your name up for 682 termination
was like tying on a blindfold grabbing a
bat and stepping up to a pinata except
in this case the Pata isn't wearing a
blindfold and somehow it can hit you
back it is a one-way ticket to
professional humiliation and if you're
unlucky enough to get too close when
things go south it can be so much worse
but Dr zarov well and truly believe that
he would be the exception to so much
miserable failure after all
this was an idea nobody had tried before
an announcement over the intercom
signaled that they had now entered sight
zero airspace they'd be landing shortly
and just like that Dr zarov was all
raised hairs and Goose flesh once again
it seemed like such a hazy distant
miracle that his project proposal would
even get majority approval from the 05
Council and now he was about to touch
down and actually see it naturally Dr
kleff noticed Dr zarov emotional cues
and like so so many playground bullies
decided to seize on it don't buy into
the hype Dr kleff said it's really not
that special the helicopter touched down
Dr zarov felt defensive he was almost
tempted to use hard words but he
realized from Dr clef's mischievous
smile that perhaps that was always the
intention he certainly had a reputation
if one were to put it in the most
neutral terms possible but this was your
001 proposal do cff zarov countered I
would have thought you'd be more
invested in this Dr clef Rose to his
feet and sheathed his Bowie knife as the
helicopter's side door opened he
gestured for Dr zarov to get up and
follow him before saying believe me even
a giant flaming demigod loses its luster
when you need to write enough of those
stupid reports on it the two researchers
disembarked from the helicopter and
walked into the legendary containment
facility site zero one of the most
important and secretive containment
sites out there even by the standards of
the ever clandestine SCP Foundation if
ever containment procedures failed here
they'd be staring down the barrel of an
unprecedented situation A Patmos XK
Class end of the world scenario after
all they were dealing with one of the
most serious and Powerful anomalies
they'd ever contained here cleen arov
entered the control room filled with
huge monitors displaying every kind of
recordable metric but the largest
screens were dominated by long range
Drone footage of the iconic anomaly they
were all there to see SCP 001 perhaps
better known as Uriel the gate Guardian
while Dr clef remained unfazed Dr zarov
felt a single tear crawling down his
cheek he had never seen an entity so
utterly on inspiring an impossibly tall
glowing humanoid entity with eight great
fiery wings and a glowing blade made of
pure Heavenly Fire every bit as hot as
the sun to think that such an incredible
creature existed on the same Earth as
him made him feel so incredibly small
the theories as to the creatures true
nature were as Myriad as they were
unknowable some of the more devout among
the foundation ranks even believe that
he is a direct servant of the abrahamic
god guarding the gate to Paradise the
Garden of Eden Heaven itself Dr clef
just
laughed everything you'd hope it'd be
zarov he said Dr zarov nodded
and more Dr cleff and more even from
such a distance the raw power of the
gate Guardian is impossible to ignore it
radiates off of the being like an
invisible Aura Dr zarov had read all the
files to get within a kilometer of the
mighty entity would be to court death
anyone who approached it would taste the
heat of its sword cleave them apart at
the atomic level and effectively erasing
them from existence it's about as dead
as anyone could possibly be save for
someone being being thrown into SCP 3930
and literally removed from the plane of
existence SCP 3930 had failed to
annihilate the hard to destroy reptile
but perhaps where that whole lot of
nothing had failed the gate Guardian
would succeed it remained floating fixed
on one place as though waiting for
something but what perhaps a fateful
confrontation with a certain reptilian
nightmare Dr zarov hoped like many he
had heard the most famous story
involving SCP 001 the gate Guardian
which took place before even the days of
the SCP Foundation after all every
Foundation needs a Founder doesn't it
and that's how it began the founder was
a mysterious figure no matter who you
ask some say it was 05- one others say
it was the legendary administrator some
even believe that it was someone else
someone older someone who predated even
the current 05 Council and administrator
a wise and learn figure going on a
pilgrimage around the Known World in
hopes of expanding their perspective and
seeking out the strange and unusual it
was traveling down the river Tigress
that the founder encountered the gate
guardian of course as always from a mile
away the founder saw the distant glowing
Point shaped like a human being with
wings it was unlike anything they'd ever
borne witness to that's when the founder
felt a door open in the back of their
mind and something sneak in a single
word projecting somehow infinite
Authority
prepare the very presence of the word
made the Founder's body rattle never had
they heard such a voice conveying such
certainty and power it had to be the
voice of the distant glowing figure it
couldn't be anything else could it much
like Dr zarov would experience hundreds
of years later the founder even as a
person so powerful knowledgeable and
influential suddenly felt so
unimaginably small the founder became
aware of not just the extent of the
world around them or even the universe
but a terrifying Multiverse of
possibilities there was light out there
of course but even more darkness and
terrifying things were hiding in the
dark is that what prepare meant did it
mean to be ready for all the Terrible
Things hiding in the dark just waiting
for the opportunity to strike just how
great was the extent of the things
Humanity didn't understand out there the
Founder's mind was flooded with with so
many possibilities if there was a tide
of monsters in the Blackness that needed
to be fought back it was too much for
any one person to ever handle the
founder needed a group all gathered
around the same mission to contain the
coming threat that the great glowing
being had warned them about people of
focus commitment and sheer willpower
people who would accept the knowledge of
the Terrible Things in the darkness and
still not waver in the face of their
great and Noble challenge people who if
necessary would be willing to die in the
dark so that the rest of the human race
would live in the light they would be
Humanity's greatest Defenders even
though they would defend in secret this
was how it had all begun supposedly Dr
zarov had heard the story whispered many
times while conducting his research into
scp1 and now here he stood perhaps where
the founder had been standing all those
years ago the SCP Foundation had faced
down greater threats than SCP 682 the
hanged King the sealed King The Scarlet
King now if they wanted to they could go
to- to- Toe with the Burger King and all
of that had begun with a single word
from the mighty gate Guardian surely an
orary overgrown lizard wouldn't be too
much for it to handle but of course they
hadn't just come here to look at the
gate Guardian that'd be an egregious
waste of time and helicopter fuel they'd
come here transporting Precious Cargo a
chunk of SCP 682s flesh cut from the
Beast itself currently it was attached
to yet another remote controlled drone
set on a collision course for the gate
Guardian Dr zarov watched the video
feeds with sweaty Palms as he saw the
Drone and its diabolical cargo enter the
video's View getting closer to the gate
Guardian by the moment Closer Closer
until the gate Guardian struck out with
its great and terrible sword for such an
astronomically huge being to move so
incredibly fast was astounding in and of
itself but what Dr zarov found even more
exciting was the result in one quick
slash of its solar blade both the Drone
and the SCP 682 tissue sample were
utterly evaporated gone reduced to less
than even Ash Dr zarov face split into a
manine if it could destroy the tissue
sample then surely it could destroy the
monster itself
and what a glorious day that would be
Meanwhile Back At The Cross testing
chambers of site 19 SCP 682 was having
another miserable day it was dragged
half melted out of its acid tank at 3:00
a.m. in the morning and left slowly
regenerating on the floor a typical SCP
Foundation wakeup call it thought to
itself with a role of its still
regenerating eyes what form of horrible
torment would be in store for it this
time it began scrolling through its
mental Rolodex for the most recent
failed but painful termination attempts
oh yes of course they tried Suffocation
via vacuum that definitely made SCP 682
feel a little lightheaded at least until
of course it adapted its body to begin
releasing a gas of similar composition
to its native atmosphere which had
certainly given those white-coated
wearing ssts a lot to take note about
then how could it forget they tried
roasting it to death with extremely high
temperatures thankfully as always it had
a trick up its sleeve adapting a carrase
made of solid helium to defend it from
the fire then shattering it to shred a
bunch of those buffoons in the orange
jumpsuits then they'd cut off a sample
of its flesh shoved it into some absurd
industrial blender before shoving what's
left into a centrifuge what a Divine
pleasure it had been for 682 to hear the
explosion down the hall when the
antimatter embedded in its jeans went
off and put a number of those idiotic
Foundation drones in the hospital for
months s them right to continually
meddling in the matters of forces they
couldn't even hope to understand and
today they were feeding at the carcass
of a dead cow SCP 682 side it felt
sometimes that adults testing it had
forgotten the note reading highly
intelligent on its file being dragged
into one of those Gastly Chambers and
given some form of Novel stimulus could
only mean one thing something stupid and
painful was going to happen said stupid
painful thing in this case was that the
cow was spiked with an instance of SCP
3521 also known as the banana Pill by
dat What followed was a remarkably
absurd instance even by SCP 682 cross
test standards where a huge number of
bananas spontaneously burst out of 682s
body being a big fan of bananas
apparently 682 was actually able to eat
and metabolize the bananas faster than
the anomalous banana Pill by dto could
produce them and because bananas are
each individual ually slightly
radioactive 682 was able to synthesize
this Collective radiation into a
powerful death ray that it used to cause
a great deal of death and destruction as
far as Dr zarov and the rest of the SCP
Foundation were concerned this thing
being cleaved apart on an atomic level
by the gate Guardian couldn't come soon
enough sometimes it took the ultimate
Knight to slay the Ultimate Dragon not
long after that SCP 682 was dosed up on
enough sedatives to give New York City a
weekl long nap and carded over to site
zero on a heavily secured armored Convoy
taking SCP 682 this far between
containment sites was considered a
matter of grave seriousness in other
words the result of this little
experiment better have been good to
justify the insane security risk it took
to even get the damn lizard out here Dr
zarov and Dr cleff decided to
co-supervise the Cross test from the
safety of the sight zero observation
deck either would have been foolish to
want to get any closer even Dr kle while
undeniably a loose cannon didn't have an
outright Death Wish unless of course
wishing death on SCP 682 would count 682
sedated body was strapped to a large
unmanned vehicle the kind they might use
for an exploratory mission on another
planet and sent in the direction of the
gate guardian's deadly proximal Zone a
secondary camera drone was also sent in
to lag behind correctly predicting that
when the gate Guardian struck SCP 682 to
it would obliterate the unmanned vehicle
too and whatever happened out there the
foundation needed it on camera Dr zarov
had sweaty palms and gritted teeth
seeing the culmination of his
professional career unfold in front of
him Dr cleff was looking at a meme on
his phone as 682 got closer it began
hearing a booming voice in its head just
like the founder had so long ago the
voice simply said one word over and over
getting louder as the unmanned vehicle
brought the two Titans closer and closer
and closer
die 682 still feeling groggy thought oh
if it only were so simple and then it
happened SCP 682 entered the dreaded 1
km range the guardian slashed down with
its mighty sword creating a brilliant
flash of light in the aftermath the
unmanned vehicle was obliterated and 682
was left heavily injured on the ground
still trying to to process what had just
happened 682 looked up sobered by the
pain and saw the being that had dealt
this blow 682 began to sneer is this
meant to be the garden it said before
breaking into a venomous
laugh this is not the garden the garden
is far west of here the gate Guardian
struck again with its flaming blade once
again projecting that single word die
die die die die When the Smoke cleared
682 was even more horrifically injured
with only one limb left but still
Against All Odds alive it used the one
limb to drag itself towards the gate
Guardian fueled by pure rage and spite
die you command me to die oh wouldn't we
all like that but this is my curse for
suggesting the fruit the reptile growled
back at the the base Dr zarov was
mortified how could it possibly be
surviving all this the sword was meant
to cleave apart its victims on an atomic
level Atomic it's in freaking atams
godamn it Dr zarov wish he had a paper
bag to breathe into Dr klef showing an
uncharacteristic degree of compassion
patted zarov on the back saying it's
okay buddy we all remember our first
time back at the center of the action
the gate Guardian blasted 682 with its
solar blade again somehow despite the
Terri Ying power wielded by the guardian
682 continued to live it was alive
barely but after three strikes from The
Sword to be alive with whatever the evil
version of a miracle would be this is
not the garden and you are not yuel 682
roared before spitting at the gate
Guardian
Pretender one more violent strike from
the gate guardian and 682 finally
collapsed unconscious from the extent of
its pain and its injuries but despite
all of Dr zarov hopes the gate Guardian
did not strike a killing blow on the
unconscious Beast instead it transmitted
another word another order impossible
for any human being to ignore
remove as though in a trance the workers
of site zero including Dr zarov and Dr
cleff entered the Forbidden 1 km
exclusion Zone the gate Guardian allowed
them safe Passage as they used tools and
vehicles to pick up the heavily injured
SCP 682 and card it away from the gate
Guardians feet after they all came back
to their senses Dr zarov simply said
what just happened Dr cleff just
Shrugged I've learned to stop
questioning it say kids would you like
to hear a story cuz we've got a really
good one for you seriously you're going
to love it it's a classic rags to Rich's
tale about one man's rise from Humble
Beginnings to become one of History's
Greatest and most Visionary toy makers
or maybe it isn't maybe it's about a
company that literally came from nothing
whose Origins are still shrouded in
mystery maybe it's about a woman
breaking the glass ceiling to take over
the toy company left to her by her
eccentric father maybe it's about all of
these things but the one thing we can
tell you about the story of Dr Wonder
tainment is that every word of it is
true or at least as far as anything is
true in the weird wonderful world of the
SCP Foundation as long as you believe
we'll all have a wonderful time as long
as you believe nothing can hurt you not
in the fabulous world of Dr Wonder
tainment Dr Wonder tainment is the name
given to SCP 001 who due to his
relatively benign Nature has been
classified as safe by the foundation
rather than focusing on containing one
entertainment himself the SCP Foundation
has centered its efforts on containing
the products that he creates he is a
Class one reality warper capable of
constructing otherwise normal objects
and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially dangerous toys
in games that are distributed by as yet
unknown means many of Wonder tainment
toys are in The foundation's Possession
such as CP 445 origami paper that takes
on properties of whatever it's folded to
look like and SCP 3147 lollipops that
allow people to switch voices with each
other Dr Wonder tainment was born into a
family of humble means his mother was a
seamstress and his father was an
accountant unsatisfied with his mundane
life wain's only joy growing up was in
the stories that his father would tell
him about an ancestor of his who was
once a famous to toy maker inspired by
these stories Wonder tainment developed
an interest in crafting toys and as an
adult set out to learn the secrets he
would need to create toys unlike
anything the world had ever seen he
spent his life following rumors of
magical artifacts and Enchanted trinkets
until his search brought him to a
mysterious Factory if you've seen our
previous videos on SCP 001 proposals you
can probably guess that this Factory was
the factory the mysterious place where
new scps are supposedly created
wonderment barely escaped the massacre
and the foundation takeover of the
factory with his life but he was able to
find a variety of notes that he took
with him these notes contained clues
that led him to the workshop of his
famous toy maker ancestor and from there
he reclaimed his Birthright that was the
day that he truly became do Wonder
tainment it's a fun story isn't it very
straightforward but perhaps it is a
little underwhelming for an scp1
proposal after all SCP 001 is the
collective designation given to some of
the most important anomalies of all time
including many that could have
potentially been involved in the
foundation's very founding H let's start
again Reginald filbert lonol archabald
Westinghouse wondertainment thei is the
name given to SCP 001 who due to his
highly unpredictable Nature has been
classed as uid by the foundation and he
is to be detained as soon as his
location can be ascertained until he can
be captured the SCP Foundation has
focused its efforts on containing the
products that he creates he is a Class 2
reality warper capable of constructing
otherwise normal objects and imbuing
them with anomalous properties he's
become infamous for using this ability
to create bizarre magical and potenti
potentially dangerous toys games candies
soft drinks and other products aimed at
children and young teens these products
are distributed by as yet unknown means
many of Wonder T's Creations are in
Foundation possession such as the often
imitated but never matched little mis's
collection which are a group of living
Collectibles with unique anomalous
properties due to entertainment's
reality warping abilities it is
impossible to pin down concrete
information about his history
what we can tell you for sure is that
he's Immortal and ageless and comes from
a long line of Wonder tainments
stretching all the way back to the
Cretaceous Period where they made all
sorts of toys for the good little
dinosaur children it's also widely known
that he is in fact not a real person but
merely the manifestation of the dreams
of every child on Earth brought forth
solely by the power of imagination no
confirmed sightings of Dr Wonder
tainment have ever occurred but which
Witnesses have described him as dashing
very handsome for his age and a lovely
chap capable of creating Whimsy and
wonder with a snap of his fingers he's a
tall man about the height of a piece of
string and he's immediately recognizable
by his walking stick and w-shaped
mustache it's also been reported that he
has scarring around the circumference of
both wrists almost as if his hands have
been removed and reattached at some
point however the truth of the matter is
that h no no we're telling it all wrong
again this doesn't do anything to
capture the scope of the Wonder tainment
story it needs to feel bigger more
comprehensive let's try it again Dr
Wonder tainment is a trademark of the
Wonder tainment toy company the name
given to SCP 001 a corporation that due
to its consistent output of anomalous
items is classed by the foundation as
ker until this company can be
permanently shut down the SCP Foundation
has focused itself efforts on containing
the products that it creates the
collective power of the company's
constituent employees and the technology
they make use are equivalent to that of
a class 3 reality warper the
wondertainment company produces and
sells a range of products ranging from
the seemingly normal to the downright
weird all imbued with anomalous
properties the company has become
infamous for their constant output of
bizarre magical and potentially
dangerous toys games candy soft drinks
and other products aimed at children
teens and young ate heart adults these
products are made and distributed from
Wonderworld trademark a location that is
yet unknown to the foundation but offers
factory tours every hour from Tuesday to
Friday many of wain's Creations are in
Foundation possession such as Wonder
tainment famous Dragon snails the real
fire breathing pet you can keep in your
pocket not much is known about the inner
workings of the Wonder tainment company
the SCP Foundation has no information
currently on the company's leadership
structure location history or corporate
policies various former and current
employees have been interviewed
regarding their experiences working for
wondertainment but they never seem to be
able to remember very much of use those
interviewed variously describe the
wondertainment company as a regular
office building an immense Toy Factory
an amusement park but all agree it's the
best place they ever worked in fact you
should apply for a job there we I I mean
have a few openings in their legal
department or so I've heard oh silly me
it seems we've gotten off topic you're
here to hear about the SCP 001 proposal
posting a job ad wasn't what I meant to
do when I hacked
into I mean well don't worry about that
forget I said a thing now let's try this
again but this time we'll add a Twist
Isabelle Helga Anastasia PVA wonderment
the 5 is the name given to to SCP 001
who due to her ability to spread
sunshine and Whimsy wherever she goes
has been classed as Thal by the
foundation and due to her immensely
unpredictable nature the SCP Foundation
has resolved to just leave her be
because she can't be captured the SCP
Foundation has focused its efforts on
containing the products that she creates
she is a class 4 reality warper capable
of constructing wonderful fantastic
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties she is famous and widely
beloved for using this ability to create
bizarre magical and not even a little
bit dangerous toys games candy soft
drinks and other products aimed at
everyone from ages 9 to 99 these
products are distributed by as yet
unknown means many of wain's Creations
are in Foundation possession such as SCP
3551 the awesome inflatable Alien
Invaders and SCP 2514 a lovely horse who
can sing Happy
Birthday how grabed Wonder tainment
inherited the Wonder tainment name from
her father who either passed away or
never existed at all the circumstances
of his death and perhaps non-existence
were very messy involving a mass
murderer the leader of a shadowy
international extra governmental
paramilitary organization at least one
deity and four bent paper clits she owns
Six corgis and all of them are named
Jeremy in a free time she likes
to no no this is all still wrong all
right enough is enough you want to know
who Dr wonderment really is well you
asked for it Dr wonderment is the name
given to SCP
001 who due to his deity level power has
been classed as aolon by the foundation
there is no possible way to contain him
he is a class five reality warper
capable of breaking down and
reconstructing the very l of reality did
you really think that those little
trinkets were the full extent of my I
mean his Creations did you truly think
of him as such a small Petty creature Dr
Wonder tainment is no mere toysmith no
he is a god want examples of his
Creations just look around you
everything from the most innocent safe
class to the most harrowing ker class
it's all thanks to him he is behind
everything Marshall Carter and dark the
sarst the Church of the broken God even
the Scarlet King himself all that time
all that effort all it came down to was
one entity One Singular living
personification of chaos one day the SCP
Foundation will finally give up trying
to find out how he distributes his
products when they will finally see how
small and worthless their attempts to
restore order really are and they will
be driven before his power they will
crumble and Decay into nothingness you
will bow before Dr Wonder
tainment had you going for a second
there didn't we you should have seen the
looks on your faces but let's start
again one more time we're being serious
this time mask off here's the true story
of Dr Wonder tainment Dr Wonder tainment
is the name given to SCP 001 who due to
his relatively benign Nature has been
classed as neutralized by the foundation
rather than focusing on containing
Wonder tainment himself the SCP
Foundation has focused its efforts on
containing the products that he creates
he is a reality warper whose limits have
yet to be documented capable of
constructing otherwise normal objects
and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially dangerous toys
in games that are distributed by as yet
unknown means due to his secretive
nature almost nothing is known of Dr
Wonder tainments true Origins and the
waters have been muddied extensively by
the side effects of his reality warping
ability in fact it's entirely possible
that Dr wonderment himself doesn't know
who he is anymore it's possible that all
the proposed Origins and descriptions of
Dr Wonder tainment are true in their own
way but it is equally possible that none
of them are all that's known for sure is
that do Wonder tainment be they male or
female Corporation or single individual
is a constant thorn in the SCP
Foundation side no matter who they
really are they're not going away soon
and only time will tell who they'll be
tomorrow or what further Horrors they
and their company will create and that's
where our story will have to come to an
end at least for now we hope you enjoyed
it and remember keep believing hour one
there is only one news story on every
website newspaper and TV screen the
flowers are blooming everywhere all
across the globe every country every
landmass the bitter cold of the
Antarctic gives way to a glowing rainbow
of petal
the Sahara Desert and Death Valley
become beacons of thriving Technicolor
plant life the highest mountains the
lowest valleys the darkest caves the
flowers even burst free from the
concrete of cities as if reminding us
that really it was never our world we
were only borrowing it and today our
lease is up this is SCP
001 object class unnecessary it was
foretold by Tales from other dimensions
a distant future coming down the tracks
towards us and today the train has
reached the station nobody's reporting
on how the economy or the stock market
is doing today no point celebrity
scandals have faded away into
nothingness greedy businessmen lying
politicians brutal tyrants none of them
are making the headlines today the very
last headlines the world gone beautiful
and what a shame it takes the end of it
all to make us realize what really
matters to us that's right you're
looking at the end of the world but it's
okay don't panic take a deep breath in
and out it was bound to happen
eventually so no point worrying now even
the foundation knows that this just
isn't something they can stop so instead
of asking things like how can we prevent
this or do we have any final tricks up
our sleev let's ask a different question
entirely what would you do if you knew
that you only had 24 hours until all
life on Earth ends think hard after all
even if you never lived to see the
flowers bloom a final day will still
come for you just as it does for us all
hour six a declass sits alone in the
cell when he sees the flowers growing
out of the ground normally he'd assume
that this meant he was in some kind of
foundation exper experiment but not
today everyone on Earth had an innate
sense that the time is now a kind of
gallows calm spreads out over everyone
and everything it's over and that's okay
we all knew it was going to happen
eventually right he sigh and gives a
slight smile those flowers sure are
beautiful that's when he hears footsteps
outside his cell approaching a key
slides into his cell door and opens
there stands Dr gears holding a bottle
of wine mine and two glasses anyone who
knows him might think he's been replaced
by some kind of shape-shifting anomaly
or had his mind taken over by a powerful
Cognito Hazard but now it's him the
famously cold Dr Charles Ogden gears Dr
gears says come on it's a lovely day out
there it'd be a terrible waste to spend
the whole thing cooped up in here it'd
feel like a trick on any day but this
the declass nods and follows the doctor
out the normally o so Foundation senior
researcher pours himself in the d-class
each a glass of wine and asks What's
Your Name by the way I don't think I
ever checked the d-class replies that
his name is Harold the two smile and
Shad as they exit the now empty d-class
containment Wing everyone else is
outside already researchers guards
administrative staff and DCL classes all
rubbing elbows enjoying the beautiful
sun on their last day together Elsewhere
on site a flock of SCP 514 is released
just as identical flocks are being
released from every containment site all
over the world they've prepared it all
for this very day SCP 514 is a special
breed of homing pigeons created by the
Mana charitable Foundation which have
the power to suppress aggression for
those within their field of anomalous
influence and now millions of them are
flying all over the world after all
there's no point fighting on a day like
this there is no future left to secure
people always told there would forever
be hope until the flowers bloomed no
situation was ever truly over until the
World Went beautiful but in the absence
of Hope there was something even more
inviting total absolute calm the sight
19 Personnel sit together and watch the
flowers bloom hour 12 all militaries
call a global ceasefire soldiers from
opposing sides hug and shake hands in
Flowery fields that once seemed choked
by death and blood borders fade bitter
rivalries turn to dust Korea unifies all
is quiet in the Middle East gangsters
and drug cartels drop their weapons and
return home to their families and
friends as flocks of SCP 514 Fly Above
what good is all the blood money in the
world on a day like this wardens walk
cell to cell through all the world's
prisons granting people their freedom
again sometimes after lifetimes of not
having it they taste the air again feel
the Sun on their face they close their
eyes drink it in and walk among the
flowers free men locations of Marshall
Carter and dark limited close their
doors and shutter their Windows
worldwide for the first time in as long
as any of them can remember they turn
their signs to closed they've earned a
day off everyone has the chaos
Insurgency rolls up their plans and
burns them they drop their weapons and
throw away their tactical gear as they
do so they they can't help but question
themselves what was it all for in the
end what was any of it for all the
fighting and bloodshed and death we did
it day after day only to do it again the
next day what silly reasons we killed
and died for what silly reasons indeed
the global cult Coalition dismisses its
staff thanking them for their service
and telling them to go spend their last
hours with the ones they love like the
foundation they accept that this is the
one true Final End no ritual to stop no
monster to fight no evil
extradimensional entity to thwart just
go outside and smell the flowers while
you still can the Serpent's hand are
similar they decide after decades
fighting a losing battle they'll spend
their last day in The Wanderers library
reading some of their favorite volumes
all these wonderful stories now left for
other Earths to read their own stories
would be counted among them in the end
and they take great comfort in that in a
sense everyone will live forever in the
pages of the books in the wanderer's
library Herman Fuller's circus of the
disquieting releases all of its Freaks
and clowns from their Twisted grasp to
go and live out whatever small dreams
and Tiny Pleasures they could find over
their last hours they have no Foundation
of fear anymore nobody Minds their
strange appearances and odd behaviors
why would anyone waste such a beautiful
day judging others on the last day on
Earth there's nothing left to prove
sarcas ists dropped their ancient flesh
bound Toms and acolytes of the broken
God put down their gilded blades on the
slopes of Siberia the jungles of Peru
and the most isolated beaches of Mexico
Twisted flesh finally touch living metal
in the spirit of husbandry their Eternal
war is at its end in the face of the
blooming World they didn't seem so
different after all the Agents of the
doctor Wonder tainment Corporation
predictably chose to spend their last
hours sitting around and playing with
toys together time well spent if you ask
us in a highly secretive location
perhaps the most heavily secured place
in the entire world the 13 members of
the legendary 05 Council decide to just
sit and talk anyone who knows anything
about this secretive cabal can tell you
the 05 Council has spent a considerable
portion of their very very long lives
trying to figure out ways to dodge and
cheat death but now facing a death they
can't Dodge the same calm washing over
the rest of the world has finally
reached them too all they can really
think this time is well played reaper
well played as they chat about the kind
of aain casual things that they haven't
had time to discuss in years 0 5-3
suggests inviting the Ethics Committee
over to join nobody disagrees hour 16 it
isn't just the DCL classes all Sapient
and non-aggressive CPS have been
released from containment free to spend
the last of their time as they wish tens
of thousands of anomalous individuals
are released from containment sites all
over the globe it'd be the greatest
victory that the Serpent's hand could
ever ask for if they weren't all too
busy reading to notice SCP 105 Iris
Thompson finally returns to her parents
the foundation had fed them the lie that
their daughter had died many years
before but as Iris had a tendency to do
she was ready to work a miracle her
parents Embrace her with open arms
they'll spend their last hours together
catching up on what's happened since
they parted ways and making up for lost
time they couldn't be happier SCP 1867
Lord Blackwood the Fantastical sea snail
is delivered into a warm Rock pool near
the site where he was being contained
there he might finally have one more
Grand Adventure before all is said and
done though afterward he may not have
the time to tell anyone about it a
terrible shame really because nobody
spins a yarn like Lord Blackwood the
non-aggressive little misters Run free
Mr Fish eagerly returns to his native
Boston Massachusetts where he enjoys one
more Lobster sandwich before the end of
the world Mr headless decides to go hat
shopping because he wants to look good
for the apocalypse Mr lost finally
settles down for the afternoon deciding
that just this once he's earned himself
a rest SCP 2800 cactusman returns to
Edinburgh to spend his last days picking
up litter and helping old ladies cross
the street SCP 3663 the tunnel monster
walks the streets of his hometown
searching for an old friend hoping to
reunite before it all ends SCP 073 Kane
decides to take a walk outside for the
first time in thousands of years he
can't help but Smile as the bright
colorful life beneath his feet is
growing faster than his presence can
kill it what a truly beautiful day
knowing that there's no longer time for
Colts to form and bother him SCP 2662
cthulu decides to take a break from his
intense Minecraft session and go take a
walk outside it feels so good to have
the sun on his tentacles once more and
to feel the lush green grass under his
suction cups he shakes his head thinking
once again about the irritating Colts
that had been pestering him for decades
what kind of idiot would want him to
destroy a world like this SCP 343 also
known as God size and looks over all his
creation for what he knows to be the
last time his mouth curls into a smile
as he thinks well we had a pretty good
run still in a Cell ASP 049 the plague
doctor puts his feet up and decides to
relax the pestilence will soon be taken
care of on some animalistic level below
thought below even instinct scp096
feels grateful that no gaze will ever
fall upon it again somewhere fizzling in
a vat of acid within a highly secure
containment chamber SCP 682 is feeling
for the first time in its hellish
existence a sense of profound relief the
pain the hate the rage the constant
termination attempts it all be over soon
our 23 people Gather in the streets they
laugh and dance and sing as the moon
shines
fat and white far above deep in their
hearts they quietly contemplate the end
of all of this but why worry why spoil
the fun there's no future left to worry
about strangers become as close as
family in the end human or otherwise
anomalous or non-anomalous chaos
Insurgency agents have last suppers with
ex- serpent hands and GOC operatives
there is no hate left no violence No
Malice no cruelty the greatest tragedy
in in all of this is that it took the
ultimate end to bring it out in people
but why worry why worry seconds pass
then minutes the world buzzes it hums
trillions of creatures doing everything
they'd wanted even though it won't last
in the face of the true end the world
has never been more alive hour 24
silence forever and ever and ever good
night we'll end this video the way it
began by putting a question to you how
would you spend your last 24 hours on
Earth let us know down in the comments
because it'll happen to all of us
eventually they came from Beyond the
world from over the world from under the
world they came from inside the stars
and from behind the rain they came from
the known lands and they came from the
secret places of old the vast ones who
drank of the nebula the small ones who
did not care what happened beyond the
banks of their Rivers the ones who
bathed in the light and the ones who
watched from the Shadows the ones who
loved us and the ones who forgot about
us the ones who hate us now and the ones
who love us still the ones who sung with
the rats and the ones who swam with the
leviathans they came from far and near
they came one and all all they came to
end the world as you may already know
from our previous video in this series a
mysterious being known only as the
harbinger unlocked SCP 001 the lock and
brought about the omn apocalypse every
single World destroying XK class
scenario on the books from Foundation
trials to the most ancient mythological
tomes and some we'd never even imagine
began to come true a world flooded with
terrifying anomalous activity from
unfurling sky eyes to Giant nightmarish
animals was about where we left off now
it's time to open your eyes and wake up
this is the kind of nightmare you can't
encounter while you're asleep SCP 5720
the astronomically inclined crane went
about its daily work the small
mechanical crane always occupied itself
with the one task that gave its
existence any meaning arranging esoteric
model solar systems but something was
different today SCP 5720 put the final
touches on its latest model and then
lifted its mechanical arm skywards
pointing directly into the vast and
Starry Infinity above but were they
Stars no not today as SCP 5720 looked up
at the sky this time the sky looked back
they weren't Stars they were eyes
something was coming towards Earth from
the furthest reaches of the outer dark
an armada of world Enders coming from
above below and and all around a whole
Cosmos of supremely powerful beings
zeroing in on our pale blue dot a
thought crossed through whatever passed
as the mind of this strange Little Crane
today is the day your prayers will be
answered followed by another word
ringing loud and clear and holy as a
mighty church bell
awaken and at that moment everything did
thousands of miles away a new God landed
on Earth appearing like a great wall of
dense matted fur descending from the sky
Ur Anum the mother of the ones that came
before after eons of absence she had
eventually returned to greet her
children the true rulers and stewards of
this land but Ur Anum was surprised and
horrified by what she saw their great
cities their sprawling structures their
beautiful art and advanced culture all
gone laid to waste by by the worthless
hairless Apes that once lurked in the
forests with the other animals something
had happened something had changed the
humans had slaughtered her people
destroyed their accomplishments
tarnished their legacy driven the few
that were left out of Their Kingdoms and
into the forests treated them as mere
animals and built their hideous concrete
cities over their bones and they had the
G to call them Bigfoot or SCP 1000
because than thanks to them their
beautiful true name had been lost to
time she looked skywards and cried out
in Despair and anguish at the loss of
her children inconsolable but then she
felt something a glimmer of hope in her
mind the possibility that things would
change that the humans would be toppled
from their Thrones and True Justice
would be achieved she called out to her
remaining children and her children
answered across the globe another great
entity awoke deep underneath a mountain
when it stirred into life and broke free
it shattered the entire Mountain on top
of it as easily as you were me
displacing a bed sheet it took to the
skies massive but unseeable to the human
eye it soared through the air gazing
down upon the world it hadn't seen for
thousands of years once it had feasted
on the blood sacrifices of human
subjects hoping to avoid its wrath but
humans weren't the petty little group of
huddled cavemen that they had once been
now they were in their billions gathered
in impossibly large settlements The
Entity sought to find a seat of power
that it could influence but now it was
spoiled for Choice eventually it zeroed
in and found its perfect Target an SCP
Foundation containment site here it
would find a new form to take and more
Petty pathetic humans to bring under its
Mighty thrw it landed in SCP
765 the duck pond it is an anomalous
Pond that is you guessed it full of
ducks and initially induces feelings of
Serenity in its victims before later
inducing not so pleasant feelings when
the entity plummeted into the water it
began to absorb and bond with the
anomaly growing to Epic sizes as it
assumed a form that the minds of us
feeble humans could comprehend a giant
terrifying duck it released a mighty
Earth shaking quack as it plotted across
the countryside to cause Mayhem
elsewhere in Europe more violent Madness
was unfolding a crimson rooster Cod then
a Golden Rooster and then a rooster of
soot red anyone with a basic knowledge
of Norse mythology was shaking in their
boots as a mighty Beast stirred in the
heart of a desolate cave the chains that
had once held the Monstrous dog in place
now broke it Rose and licked its Jagged
fangs excited to stain them with the
blood of its enemies it was the great
hound fener omen of the end times here
to Herald the end of all things a
trumpet had boomed across the globe with
no Apparent Source people in the streets
in New York Delhi London Cape Town and
countless other towns cities and hamlets
the world over paused and listened in
confusion below them the great and
terrible jonga the thought to be
mythological midgard serpent stirred
from its previously Eternal Slumber and
began to uncoil its body the shifting
caused earthquakes and tsunamis along
the coast of Greenland as towns and
Villages crumbled killing thousands
fener stalked along the length of
Denmark slaughtering and devouring
anyone or anything unlucky enough to
cross its path but it did not wage its
war against mankind alone behind it a
hellish Army of burning Giants marched
Mighty hands clutching molten weapons
Ragnarok was upon us now Odin save us
all and the administrator slept she was
the latest in a long line of foundation
staff members to hold that hollowed
position and in the dark Vista of her
dreams a predecessor approached her he
wasn't the old bearded man in the heavy
coat that she remembered now he was
wearing a 1950 suit and a fedora hat and
carrying a briefcase that's right he'd
taken up the mantle of SCP 990 also
known as the dreamman he's a mysterious
figure that appears to members of the
foundation in their dreams warning them
of impending disasters that they may be
able to nearly prevent if his warning is
heated though it often comes at some
terrible cost to the recipient of his
message this time however his message
carried a different tone he told the
current administrator that there was no
way to stop the apocalypse from
occurring this time only making sure
that the particular shape of the
Apocalypse would be the one most
favorable to the foundation and
Humanity's joint interests all this was
devastating news that the new
administrator saw as a grievous betrayal
of both the foundation stances and
Humanity as a whole she refused to
accept the idea that the apocalypse was
inevitable even coming from the mouth of
a former administrator as far as she was
concerned this dream man no longer
worked on the side of the foundation he
was in League with the world Enders and
she refused to take his deal the SCP
Foundation would save this world from
the horrors the lock Unleashed or they
would slide into the darkness with it
they would never work against the human
race SCP 343 also known as God awoke in
his cell in sight 17 the time for fun
and games with the humans at the
foundation had come and gone he was
going by his true name Yahweh now he
blinked and in that same instant he was
at site zero the containment site for
another SCP 001 the legendary gate
Guardian all the staff around them
looked upon Yahweh in Shock awed by the
reality warper sudden appearance and
unable to do anything about it but
really 343 was no mere reality warper
like some had expected 343 truly was a
god he just didn't happen to be the only
one in play When the gate Guardian saw
Yahweh now standing before him he
lowered his sword spread his fiery wings
and took a knee in great reverence
Yahweh spoke calmly but with unshakable
authority y it is time open the gate
lead my armies across the Earth the gate
Guardian Uriel responded in its booming
voice I hear and obey
my Lord and my
God for the first time in recorded
memory the grand gate that yuriel had
always been guarding opened revealing
thousands of Legions of warrior Angels
waiting on the other side they were
impossibly beautiful and Powerful
creatures each one of vibrant glowing
chaos of wings and eyes wielding Pure
White swords and singing resounding
hymns of War soon the air was thick with
the chorus of rustling wings as the
Angels loosen themselves from the gates
mouth led by Uriel as yahweh's general
into the global Fray meanwhile back at
site 10 another SCP 001 the item that
started all of this the lock was
entering its next stage of grand Cosmic
Evolution something within the lock
suddenly unfurled causing a Shockwave
that killed everyone at the site and
destroying the entire building in an
instant except in that same instant all
of the sight 10 staff and the building
itself reappeared completely unharmed in
a field in New Hampshire back where
saiten used to be the lock was doing
some terraforming the ground split open
beneath into a mighty Valley the likes
of which Earth had never seen before
Lush Greenery sprouted within and
thousands of strange alien creatures
soon populated this new place in the
center the lock just floated in place
they were now ready for the first
meeting to take place over at site 2036
Dr Everett Mann was working on a number
of SCP 098 specimens these are
frightening creatures reminiscent of
spider crafts with blades instead of
Pinchers and a natural ability to mimic
the sounds of their prey he was studying
the creatures when he got a call asking
him if the specimens had acted up at all
they had already had sudden containment
breaches for SCP 995 a type of dangerous
carnivorous fungi and SCP 66
a mysterious airplane with satanic
elements to it just as Dr man was about
to reply the 098 specimens
metamorphosized into many wied flying
creatures which flew out of the chamber
with such force that they busted through
walls Sirens blared all through the
facility and Dr man joined the many
other confused and frustrated Foundation
staff members wandering the building
wondering just what the hell was going
on today they were getting bizarre
reports of unprecedented anomalous
activity from all over the world with no
explanation uniting at all according to
panicked Whispers across the facility
emergency order Patmos was now in effect
whatever that meant the true nature of
what was going on here went over most of
the heads of the SCP foundation's staff
that's when man encountered Dr Charles
Ogden gears who for such a famously
emotionless man looks surprisingly
worried Dr man tried to downplay the
situation saying they were only looking
at a handful of containment breaches
here nothing they hadn't handled before
Dr gears shut him down with trademark
coldness feeling a little more nervous
now Dr Everett man asked what else had
gotten out with Steely eyes Dr gears
replied a whole damn lot SCP 001 is an
05 tail it makes sense doesn't it after
all regardless of the exact nature of an
SCP 001 proposal there are always
certain things that remain the same see
if you can recall them all well for
starters SCP 00 ones are all about vital
moments perhaps like the Prototype or
the foundation or the sheath of papers
or the gate Guardian they're about the
very origin of the SCP Foundation itself
perhaps like the ororo cycle or when day
breaks or the world gone beautiful
they're about apocalyptic style
destruction or perhaps the rebirth
perhaps like consensus reality or the
database they are rules or realizations
that changed everything maybe like the
Scarlet king or the black moon or a
simple toy maker they're about the
sparking of great rivalries that truly
Define the backbone of the foundation's
activities another vital element of SCP
001 is always secrecy in classification
they are the most clandestine anomalies
out there generally hidden away below
layer after layer of encryption and
Security even the database for SCP 001
entries is guarded by a mimic kill agent
that'll leave you stoned dead on the
ground if you're below that magical
level five clearance when when you
attempt to access it no information is
more carefully and forcefully guarded
than this and of course another vital
element of the SCP 001 entry is
deception and trickery it's inherent to
the designation no other number has
multiple entirely distinct anomalies
many of which either have no correlation
with one another or even actively
contradict each other if you ask some
people they'll tell you that there are
multiple 001's because each is of equal
importance in etching the rich portrait
of the foundation's past present and
future some would tell you something
very different there's only one SCP 001
it's a shell game the rest are all fakes
to stop people from taking any single
entry too seriously and thus forever
avoiding the truth some still would tell
you that there is no SCP 001 it's all
just a complex Web of Lies meant to keep
the foundation's enemies and allies in a
state of pliable ignorance if an
intimate knowledge of the SCP
foundation's past and inner workings a
commitment to secrecy at all costs and a
love of deception as a tool for control
all sound familiar it's because they're
the favorite toolkit of a certain group
we're all familiar with the 05 Council
the very top brass of the SCP Foundation
it only makes sense that if anyone knew
the truth about the fractured and
strange SCP 001 it would be them the
more observant among you may have
noticed a certain emission from many
popular SCP 001 entries we've Nam
dropped in this video so far and it is
no accident that this particular SCP 001
entry is the only one straight from the
mouth of
creation and growth of the foundation
the event that nearly destroyed it and
an indication as to the dark future
possibly in store it's a little bit of
everything you can expect from a good
001 proposal and surely if this is the
SCP 001 entry that the head of the
council swears by then it must be the
definitive entry into the 001 Cannon
right well not quite because as you're
about to find out not even the 05
Council itself can really reach a
consensus on the true nature of the
fascinating and much-feared Factory but
perhaps through hearing every side of
this particularly dark story we can find
the kernels of Truth hidden somewhere in
the middle of it all but of course be
warned as with all things when it comes
to the 05 Council it's going to get
extremely weird but before we move on to
what the rest of the 05 Council have to
say about the factory it would be
prudent to refresh our memory on 05-
one's version of the story the version
that has been considered to be absolute
before we pour into the equally strange
stories of the other council members it
began with a wealthy industrialist and
thoroughly evil man named James Anderson
all the way back in
1835 when the United States was still
new and finding its feet Anderson was an
engine of unchecked ambition malice and
most of all truly boundless greed he
wanted everything and more and being a
true businessman down to the core he was
willing to make whatever deal he needed
to make in order to see himself become
an even wealthier man that's why like a
lot of board rich people in his day he
began dabbling in the dark arts for Fun
and Profit until eventually he made
contact with a benefactor on the other
side under these instructions James
Anderson built the factory a truly
magnificent and terrible feat of
architecture and engineering for the
time a multi-level towns siiz complex
that could produce everything from food
to weapons to toys to textiles to
precious metals and so much more workers
could find room and board at this Grand
Factory and pay for it with their labor
for the wouldbe workers of an unsteady
early America Anderson seemed like a
saint people flocked from all over the
country to live and work in the factory
but once they were locked behind the
Factory's doors they realized that James
Anderson was no saint he was as bad or
worse than devil he served the inside of
the factory was a torturous nightmare
where people were regularly worked to
death and then ground into meat that was
sold off all across the country Anderson
kept a brutal guard Force to beat down
anyone resisting or not working hard
enough those who weren't worked to death
or executed by the guards for some petty
infraction could potentially have an
even worse fate in store for them being
dragged off and subjected to occult
experiments by Anderson these people
wouldn't be killed but they would live
as humans no more Anderson was able to
keep the factory and its nightmarish
activities running and under wraps for
decades all the way into the Civil War
it was only when a beaten bloody starved
and traumatized worker managed to escape
and alert president ulyses S Grant of
the mistreatment going on inside that
something was done about it this is
where 051 and a progenitor of the SCP
Foundation would get involved there was
a small but Elite group of Union
Soldiers commissioned by President Grant
to work behind the Confederate lines
specializing in tackling the strange and
Supernatural down south this group of
course was led by 05- one considering
some of the reports of anomalous
Supernatural activity going on behind
the closed doors of the Anderson Factory
Grant knew that these would be the men
to send on this vital Mission and
president Grant's faith in these men was
rewarded though it wasn't an easy fight
they were able to infiltrate and defeat
the forces of the factory they fought
their way through Anderson's sadistic
guards through his menagerie of
terrifying homemade monsters and
eventually they got to Anderson himself
they were so appalled by the horrors
they'd seen inside the factory they
couldn't stop themselves from torturing
Anderson to death and dismembering his
corpse they freed the trapped workers
and rooted out whatever remained of
Anderson's forces within the building
however this is where they made their
first pivotal decision rather than
simply destroying the sworded place and
leaving it as Rubble they instead
decided to utilize it and the many
anomalous objects that It produced this
became the foundation of the foundation
over time their organization grew and
the 05 Council was formed they began
spreading their influence and capturing
anomalies all over this was however
until they engaged in a bloody war with
the superior military forces of the Fay
despite their augmented weaponry and
tools from the factory when the the Fay
performed an allout assault against them
they were decimated in his greatest
shame 05- one fled the battlefield into
the bows of the factory as his friends
and allies were slaughtered by the Fay
behind him eventually after locking
himself in a room with an ornate door he
encountered the true demonic heart of
the factory using Anderson's dismembered
corpse as a mouthpiece 0 5-1 struck a
terrible deal with the factory they
wiped out the Fay entirely and reversed
all the damage they had done the SCP
Foundation grew beyond the factory and
eventually covered it in rubble out of
shame but the factory wasn't done it is
still very much alive and Furious at
being betrayed it will keep producing
deadly anomalous objects and creatures
and releasing them out into the world
until the foundation pays what it owes
in full and the occasional sacrifice
declass researcher and guard won't cut
it forever or at least that's how 05-
one tells it it's a chilling story but
can it really be called a complete one
we wanted to find out for ourselves
which is why we asked every other member
of the 05 Council to tell their side of
the Factory's tale these are 12 tales
about a factory 05-25-18
line of the present he was a mere
researcher until an accident led him to
being completely unored from time he was
thrown all over the temporal landscape
he saw civilizations rise and fall he
took the time to hang out with Jesus he
was a pretty chill guy and ultimately he
decided the best way to use his bizarre
new condition was to help better the
future with his knowledge one piece of
technology he brought back was a hyper
advanced piece of technology known as a
nanofactory which as the name suggests
is a machine that uses Nanobots to
construct pretty much anything like the
ultimate futuristic 3D printer it
resulted in the creation of a huge
number of futuristic items that helped
the SCP Foundation along in their
mission to secure contain and protect
including amnestics however what
producing dangerous anomalies with
Reckless abandon to the detriment of
both the SCP Foundation and the World At
Large on the whole it was somewhat of a
mixed bag
practical reasons and to play extremely
immersive games of Doom however one day
something fundamentally changed a new
Consciousness was born in then Soviet
Russia 05-30 two of his companions all
operating in cyberspace went to go check
it out along with a few helpful AI
constructs eventually they discovered it
an ever expanding data packet that would
transform into a powerful artificial
Consciousness known as the factory with
mysterious motives and and seemingly
malicious intent something it more than
proved when it erased the mind of one of
05-30 5-4 seemed both Twitchy and
indignant when the topic was brought up
they lamented the fact that the
foundation hadn't put more research into
the factory and how to stop it because
technically it is their most dangerous
and mysterious enemy group of Interest 0
5-4 explained it as follows the FBI
unusual incidents unit is a joke are we
cool yet is just a bunch of pretentious
privileged Rich Kids Marshall Carter and
dark limited only care about money and
thus can be bought off the global occult
Coalition often helps them take care of
more challenging anomalies the Church of
the broken God and the AR ists are often
too busy waging Petty religious wars
against each other to do real meaningful
damage to the SCP Foundation Prometheus
Labs had already fallen and Doctor
Wonder tainment wouldn't Thrive forever
the factory however was a truly unknown
quantity it's just out there somewhere
pumping out anomalies that soon become
everyone else's very dangerous problem 0
5-4 personally resented that the
foundation and their fellow council
members don't see this and allocate more
resources to the cause because someday
soon it might really come back to bite
them as these things often do 05- 5 was
considerably bitter as in they denied
that the factory ever even existed
claiming that the SCP Foundation made it
up to cover up a bunch of anomalies that
they themselves had created and then
told us to um f off if you know what I
mean some people get so hostile when you
just want simple answers next came the
tale of 0 5-6 which came in the form of
a World War II Espionage anecdote of
course this was also during the height
of the seventh occultt war and Hitler
assisted by the fuel society and obscura
corpse was trying to get his greasy
little hands on as many anomalies as
possible in hopes of turning the tide of
the war in his favor 0 5-6 was working
undercover Behind Enemy Lines disguised
as an SS off officer as he slowly helped
dismantle Hitler's anomalous offensive
from within he'd heard whisperings of
the Nazis developing a weapon unlike any
other a factory that would produce
anomalies for them on demand and give
them the supernatural Edge 0 5-6 didn't
believe it at first until he was
attacked by a group of vicious living
Punch and Judy dolls created by the
factory he nearly managed to survive the
Ambush but seemed Disturbed in
recounting the fact that when he
destroyed the doll they bled profusely
eventually the leads he was following
led him to a ruin at the base of zutz
inside he discovered the ruin was Hollow
and filled with floating Stone orbs
producing energy that allowed the Teo
Society researchers to produce more
anomalies 0 5-6 was able to destroy this
anomaly Factory but he took a souvenir
SCP 627 a little Stone ball that rolls
around on the ground when it comes into
contact with people oh 5-7 admitted
somewhat sheepishly that while there was
technically no real physical factory
factory product anomalies are real and
they're all his fault he purchased a
bunch of random items from Walmart and
printed a fake logo for the factory on
the back his plan was to give these
totally innocent objects to Junior
researchers both to mess with them for
fun and to test their critical thinking
skills however it turned out that simply
placing this logo onto an item results
it in becoming an anomalous item item
admittedly it was rough for 057 to have
to follow the cool story about fighting
magic Nazis 0 5-8 made the far more
exciting claim that the factory is
actually all the way up on the moon back
when the SCP Foundation were first
founding Moonbase Alpha they discovered
that some ancient and unknown
civilization had already built a covert
base under the surface it was a
storehouse of anomalous alien technology
the first 13 people to enter were
immediately vaporized by the laser
defense system but the fourth to enter
was given an even worse fate he was
pulled into the machine and fused with
it at which point the factory was truly
activated it began to produce anomalies
and transport them to random locations
all across the globe and it's been a
problem ever since when we spoke to 05-
9 on the matter with a Steely look in
his eye he simply muttered the word
Atlantis no further comments were made
on the matter 05-10 explained that the
factory was a single man a truly ancient
and Brilliant anomalous Craftsman that
they found in a Mountain Temple in Tibet
he was taken by the foundation and
contained but given far more high-tech
tools to work his magic so they could
keep reaping the anomalous fruits of his
labors however the Craftsman was
appropriately crafty and managed to
produce a duplicate of himself to
distract the foundation while he made an
escape he's still out there to the stay
making more anomalies a one man Factory
05-11 claimed that the factory was alien
in origin but it wasn't on the moon it
was the true explanation for the iconic
1947 Roswell New Mexico UFO incident a
flying saucer descended and offered
05-11 who was the commander of the
response team at the time the most
wonderful things this saucer became the
factory but humanity and 05-11 were
deceived it wasn't long before this
extraterrestrial Factory was producing
countless deadly anomalous nightmares
the world over with nothing we could do
about it 05-12 said that the factory is
a mess it's a remnant of the
foundation's attempt to erase the
supernatural from Human belief
Foundation researchers claim that due to
the inherent power in human belief the
belief in the Supernatural gave it power
and phasing Humanity as a whole out of
this belief was a major factor in making
sure things weren't much worse than they
are today however some hearty things
slipped through the the cracks and
because reality has a strange sense of
humor these things are marked with the
logo of the factory to round things off
we have a bonus take from the mysterious
05-13 who is instrumental in helping us
put the rest of this video together he
claims that he created the factory and
that it acts as a kind of countermeasure
against interdimensional Invaders while
it may seem like the factories creating
anomalies it's actually intercepting
them and making them safer some
anomalies that seem to to come from the
factory may be dangerous but if 05-13 is
to be believed then they'd be a hell of
a lot more dangerous if the factory
wasn't here and there you have it folks
the story of the factory from every
possible angle even though it feels like
each angle is facing in an entirely
different direction in the words of
Oprah Winfrey so what is the truth is
there a nugget of reality beneath all of
the fallacy or do you think the 05
Council was trolling all of us for even
daring to ask we leave that question to
you dear viewers let us know which
Theory you believe down in the comments
below the man's bedroom hadn't been
silent for over 100 years now the carpet
had been worn down a thick layer of dust
had gathered on every surface and the
same trapped air had stagnated for so
long that it become unbearable for
anyone entering the room but no one was
allowed to enter the room nobody could
open that door ever again or it could
Mark the beginning of not just an
apocalypse but a breakdown in the nature
of reality itself figures shuffled
around the room sometimes dozens
sometimes as few as three all rotting
but never dying researchers peered
through the window in abject Terror day
after day as the laws of physics broke
down before their very eyes all of them
except one a lone scientist with a plan
to get inside that room a plan that the
foundation would shoot him dead for a
plan that he was seconds away from
enacting as the improvised explosive
device in his Satchel clunked heavily
against his thigh in many ways we are
just as trapped as SCP 001 if not more
so we are trapped in our own
three-dimensional world take a stick
figure drawn on a piece of paper that
stick figure knows up and down left and
right and that is their world you draw a
box around them and they are trapped
unable to Simply step forward out of the
page and walk around it for us looking
down at the stick figure we might laugh
at their foolishness trapped inside a
child's drawing of a house it begs the
question is there a creature looking
down at us and laughing we may be able
to move up and down left and right
forward and backward outsmarting the
simple stick figure but in time we are
just as caged in living our entire lives
on this razor thin piece of paper called
the present the future is always just
Out Of Reach reach the past always
repelling us we have no choice but to
exist in the now slowly creeping through
history without any agency of our own
curse to be born Live and Die in that
order you can never be a child again
never see your mother's face for the
first time beaming down at you you
cannot skip ahead to your dying minutes
knowing what it is you will have to face
up to in your life maybe the idea of
facing up to things at all will fade
with the freedom of exploring what once
was and what will be as if it were no
more difficult than taking a step out of
a 2d box the bell rang cutting Professor
Davies off he hadn't meant to go into
such an existential tangent especially
for his first year students most of them
looked like they were in a days not
really listening to anything he had been
saying quantum mechanics sure was a
complex topic to cover in just one
semester at University he'd spent his
entire career trying to wrap his head
around it and still spend most of his
days with the same bored and Confused
glaze over his eyes as the teenagers who
made their way to the back of the hall
but one figure standing just beyond the
doorway peering down at him caught the
professor's eye little did he know how
drastically his career was about to
change in just a few minutes a
preeminent physicist at just 28 years
old Professor Davies had already
achieved the status that many academics
will not see within their lifetimes
whenever anyone one asked him about it
he always made the joke that he was
cheating he didn't believe in the
concept of a linear lifetime in the
first place still too young to be taken
seriously by many of his peers he had
flown under the academic radar for much
of his career so far perhaps it was as
simple as that or perhaps certain
undercover agents had a hand in
suppressing news of his blossoming
career in Quantum research his hands
trembled as he approached the reinforced
glass he gripped the bag tightly trying
his best not to let his fear show if any
of them saw what he was about to do if
they even suspected something he would
have a dozen bullets flying through the
back of his skull before he'd even have
a chance to put his hands up shifting
his weight from foot to foot he waited
for the airlock to be open for him a
siren blared red lights flashed and the
first glass door slid open stepping
inside he waited for the atmosphere in
the chamber to adjust both doors were
closed in front of and behind him if
they wanted to kill him now would be the
time he closed his eyes and waited with
baited breath the bomb weighing heavily
on his shoulder but they would not kill
him he knew that now what he was about
to do was inevitable it took several
months for Professor Davies to be
granted the full security clearance he
needed they kept referring to his
project as a k class anomaly whatever
that meant in order to get him up to
speed with the nature of what he was
going to be working on the foundation
assigned him to various other CPS first
SCP 5027 2821 1887 any instance that had
some link to Quantum Mechanics or
complex theoretical physics they
wouldn't even tell him which SCP he was
being trained up to work on until one
morning when a team of Agents was
waiting for him at the door to his
quarters he wasn't allowed to bring a
bag or any personal possessions standard
issue clothing a toothbrush and
everything else he needed would all be
provided for him it was only then that
they told him which SCP he was being
assigned to SCP 001 he was blindfolded
for the entirety of the journey car then
plane then another car it was a full 10
hours before his blindfold was removed
and his new project was revealed to him
professor Davies found himself in sight
01 the place where all of this started
all the scps all the research the
secrecy the assassinations the deaths of
countless innocent people and an equal
number of guilty parties it all started
right here site 01 the site itself
resembled a large sarcophagus similar to
the one found covering the Chernobyl
nuclear power plant where do you think
the Soviets got the blueprints from
everything in the room is arranged in a
circle around the center research desks
maintenance equipment raw materials
including a stockpile of wooden planks
and reinforced Metal Sheets monitoring
equipment security cameras and of course
some of the most advanced automatic
weapon systems in the world all pointed
at a great glass box in the middle of
the hanger measuring 30 m in each
Direction the glass was 50 cm thick even
all those High Caliber weapons would
have had a hard time creating a chip in
that but it wasn't the glass box itself
that was so interesting it was what was
trapped inside of it a house inside a
perfectly round glass bowl with no
entrances or exits complete compl with a
front lawn sidewalk porch and even a
tree in the backyard a regular American
house trapped in a box like some kind of
science experiment there was some kind
of transparent airlock system at the
entrance on the other side was just a
normal walk up the garden path to the
edge of the second glass bubble
enclosing the house but on closer
inspection Professor Davies realized
that this wasn't your typical American
house at all the Street Lamp wasn't
electric it was made of iron with little
glass paint Windows an oil lamp in fact
the house did look odd to him there was
no electric doorbell but instead an
actual physical Bell System the whole
house looked out of place not just
because it was in a box in the central
hanger of a 42,000 ton sarcophagus but
because it was from another era entirely
you see sight 01 was constructed around
this house the glass box and bubble
sarcophagus all of it was built around
the already existing building beneath
the foundations 100 m beneath the
surface is an immense metal plate that
forms a perfect seal with the defenses
up top the only way in and out of site
01 is through an immense reinforced door
but even all those defenses will prove
utterly futile if anyone ever opens the
thin wooden door to the bedroom on the
top floor of the house that is the home
and the prison in which SCP 001 is
trapped it is the job of the foundation
to make sure that it remains trapped
there indefinitely what is SCP 001 as
Professor Davies made his way through
the airlock for the very first time and
entered the site under the supervision
of four of the highest ranking SCP staff
alive today he laid eyes on the entity
itself for the first time standing on a
scissor lift parked outside the front of
the house just inches away from the
glass bubble it was lifted high enough
to look through the window into what
looked like a young boy's bedroom on the
top floor layers of dust coated the
surfaces black and white photos sat in
frames antique children's toys sat all
around the walls but Davies didn't
notice any of them he was too busy
watching the men walking in all
directions unhurried but with purpose
well over a dozen men walked in all
directions across the carpeted floor
they were all identical around 6 ft with
heavy rotting skin that seemed to hang
off their limbs like it would a carcass
left in the Sun cadavers Milling about
in a young boy's bedroom Davies was so
taken back by their appearance and
behavior that it took him a long time to
notice something truly strange the
reason he was brought here in the first
place they were walking through the bed
in the middle of the room not just over
it or around it but straight through it
as if it wasn't there but wait something
else was wrong too there weren't 12 of
them in the room it was closer to 20 had
he miscounted a moment ago then he saw
it take place one of the cavers reached
the edge of the room and paused as if in
thought at that moment it split not in
half but rather two versions of itself
emerged from where one had been standing
both walking in different directions a
thrill of excitement ran through
Professor Davy's body the uncertainty
principle it was there in action in
front of him he was looking at
Schrodinger's cat inside the box and
seeing both its corpse and and its
living self where uncertainty exists
this entity was somehow embodying both
possibilities in real time he watched
the two selves walk around the room
following different paths for several
minutes until eventually they converged
again back into one being he turned to
the researcher accompanying him lit up
with excitement and asked what they were
doing here the researcher's face was
Grim when he replied they're pacing
waiting the airlock door hissed open he
felt the St Dale 1800's air hitting his
face perfectly maintained at 20° in
front of him was the Garden Path leading
up to his goal that glass bubble ripping
the Satchel he set off up the path slow
enough not to attract any unwarranted
attention over the next few days
Professor Davies learned everything that
the foundation had on SCP 001 it had
been a human once a radical physicist
born in the late 19th century intent on
kickstarting The Next Century with a
nuclear Renaissance the young man had
created a working model for stable
nuclear fusion the potential
ramifications were enormous free clean
electricity on a mass scale with no
harmful byproducts his research was
almost complete when a CT private
military group poisoned him with his own
radioactive nuclear agent the young man
made it back to his house where he died
in his sleep that night powerful
military personnel and prominent
scientists who had been working
alongside the young man knew immediately
what had happened bursting into his home
they were about to walk through his
bedroom door and save him when they saw
the shadow of two feet standing by the
door then another pair the young
scientist had died but he also hadn't
much like Schrodinger's Cat the man was
suspended in a dual state of death and
not death this shocking Discovery led
the group of people present to form a
rudimentary Foundation established to
secure and contain their once friend
within his room never to be discovered
by The Wider world through close
observations since this time it has been
established that SCP 001 exists
independently of linear time in a kind
of superposition relative to the world
around it it is capable of occupying any
space that will or has been empty at any
point in time say you have two chairs in
a room one chair has always been there
the other was added to the room just 5
minutes before the SCP is unable to walk
through the chair that was always there
since it has always existed but the
chair that was added Ed can be passed
through with no problem because there
was a point in time when that chair had
not been there but it also works in the
future if a third chair was present
which had always been there but was
removed 5 minutes after the experiment
SCP 001 could pass through that chair
also the foundation theorizes and hopes
that the start of this clock that scp1
operates on was the point at which the
young scientist died and did not die
that is why it is incapable of escaping
bedroom and that is why it is of vital
importance that the bedroom door remains
closed forever ongoing maintenance work
and preservation techniques are being
employed to keep the house in as stable
a state as possible should anything
happen to damage the Integrity of the
structure the quantum chaos contained in
that space could lead to a total
breakdown of the laws of physics
destroying not just the world but the
fundamentals of mathematics as we know
them the bomb bumped against Professor
Davy's thigh as he walked up to the
house an old man whose life had been
devoted to denying the world its future
a reality where what is and what could
be are just as real as one another a
world where the pain of living in the
now Fades when you can travel to any
moment in your life and relive its Joy
when you aren't trapped by the aging
process infinite renewable energy to
solve The World's problems a chance to
see your deceased loved ones again a way
to look at the universe through the eye
of God the head of 001 containment he
had spent his entire career overriding
all of the safeguards tweaking
containment rules just enough each year
all so he could walk across this grass
with a satchel on his shoulder and an
explosive more important than the atomic
bomb at his hip he approached the glass
of the inner sphere if he had done the
math right this should do just enough
damage to create a hole in the
containment structure the pressure
change wouldn't be too great inside but
it should be just enough to blow say a
bedroom door wide open the woman fell to
the ground clutching her ankle in pain
it had crunched badly as she'd fallen
and now as she looked down at it she
could see that it was been totally out
of shape the heavy metal collar choking
her neck made it difficult for her to
catch her breath as she tried her best
not to hyperventilate the rain was
hammering down so ferociously that she
could barely see more than 20 ft in any
direction but she didn't need to see far
to know how deadly of a predicament she
had found herself in she cried out at
the top of her voice for someone to come
and find her anyone but the only sound
that filled her ears was the wild
howling of the wind and the steady
hammering of water into the bog all
around her she would get hypothermia and
die no wait she couldn't could she she
knew she couldn't die but she also knew
that she was still capable of suffering
just how bad would it feel to be in the
clutches of hypothermia with a broken
ankle and know that no matter how bad
the pain and suffering got she would
never feel the release of death she
closed her eyes trying her best not to
think of the worst possibilities just as
the sound of gunfire erupted in the
nearby buffer she cried out again
holding both hands up in the air doing
the best she could around the heavy
metal collar but no one shouted out in
reply there was a pause in the gunfire
maybe they'd heard her maybe they were
trying to figure out a way to come down
and rescue her crack a bullet split open
a rotted tree trunk just a few feet to
her right the woman threw her hands over
her head and cowered in the dirt feeling
the metal of her collar digging into her
skin tighter than ever please don't let
it happen again she prayed silently into
the dirt Inc cased in the collar around
her neck were 4.5 kg of plastic
explosives each with a fragment mation
layer pointed inwards towards her neck
and head with just a push of a button
they could she didn't want to think
about it all she knew was that she
couldn't let that happen to her again
looking through eyes bloodied with tears
and Rain she saw lying in the dirt just
a few feet away from her that infernal
machine that was the sorry cause of all
of this the SCP Foundation has long
stood as a Bastion of Hope information
and security for the entirety of the
human race I'm sure you are well aware
of the number of world destroying
catastrophes that have been adverted by
the hardworking researchers agents and
other members of the foundation all
without the general public having the
slightest clue that something was a Miss
with state-of-the-art holding cells all
over the globe and the sharpest Minds
Humanity has ever produced working
around the clock to ensure the
protection of humanity it is hard to
imagine an entity that should not be
contained by such a group and yet one
such entity does exist SCP
001 you may have come across the 05
Council by this point while the SCP
Foundation operates beyond the world's
jurisdiction the 05 Council operates
beyond the foundation's jurisdiction the
rules methods and protocols that are the
Cornerstone of securing containing and
protecting countless entities around the
world sometimes cannot be applied
certain entities require us to
temporarily abandon our Humanity abandon
our sense of order and step briefly into
chaos for the greater good I'm telling
you all of this because SCP 00001 is not
held in a containment cell there are no
keypads locked doors observation windows
or health and safety forms SCP 001 is
not confined to a specific territory or
even a specific country for some scps
this is a practical necessity Sur that
are hundreds of kilometers long swimming
through the depths of the ocean for
example but for SCP 001 it serves a more
psychological purpose the Scottish
Highlands are the most remote part of
the United Kingdom out there you can
walk for miles and miles without seeing
a single soul open Countryside mountains
locks and forests surround you in all
directions the weather is Harsh and
unrelenting the walking even more so on
a regular basis walkers fall and break
their legs but without phone service or
anyone else nearby to come and help they
can quickly disappear into the
Wilderness forever the Beet bogs of
Scotland used to see human sacrifices in
early settlements afraid of the ghosts
and spirits that haunted the bogs people
would throw their family members into
the deepest parts and watch them drown
hoping that whatever was lurking beneath
wouldn't come and find them so as the
group of soldiers crusted the top of the
mountain and looked down beneath them to
the Eerie Pete bogs obscured by mist and
constant rainfall you would forgive a
shiver running up their spines but of
course it didn't that was because this
group of soldiers were quite unlike any
others that Humanity has ever produced
all were nameless none of them existed
on any government databases on any
foundation databases or even on the
databases of the 05 Council itself their
individual backgrounds nationality and
families were totally unknown to
everyone other than themselves some had
been tortured for years others had been
the torturers the thing that United them
however was their inhuman ruthlessness a
squad of eight soldiers utterly devoid
of any sense of empathy what could they
possibly have to be afraid of in the
Pete bogs when they themselves were the
evil ghosts walking through but then one
person was afraid a shiver ran up her
spine as she looked over the edge and
down into the murky black and green
below
scp1 D1 around her neck was the bomb
collar each of the eight soldiers
surrounding her had a button mounted on
a watch on the back of their wrists at
any moment any one of them could hit the
button and all 4 and 1/2 kg of plastic
explosives would go off sending her on
an Express trip to Oblivion aside from
the collar she wore a plain white dress
made of cotton it was muddy and torn
apart at the Hem from Days of walking
through the Scottish Wilderness when she
had first arrived she had begged those
around her to supply her with some warm
clothes something practical that would
keep her comfortable and Stave off any
illness her requests however had not
been acknowledged clutching in her
trembling outstretched hands was the
machine SCP 001 d a from its external
experience you would think it was
nothing more than a wooden B box a
perfect cuboid made from glossy dark
wood there were no symbols no seams no
latches nothing to indicate any method
of operation when the woman in the
machine had first been delivered into
the hands of the 05 Council the
researchers had spent weeks and millions
of dollars trying to activate the
machine their best scientists had
scanned for every possible form of
radiation and tried every method they
could conceive to stimulate the box into
opening the ultimate failed attempt
involved traveling to North Korea where
they negotiated placing the Box 20 cm
beneath a small nuclear warhead in
return for granting the dictatorship key
information on how to construct such a
weapon as we have established the 05
Council operates Beyond any kind of
jurisdiction yet at the bottom of the
irradiated crater set a perfectly intact
wooden box that was cool to the touch
and showed no signs of radioactivity
only one person could interact with the
Box and Unearthed the secrets that were
inside SCP
01-1 the woman who stood trembling on
the side of the mountain a gun jabbed
her in the back forcing her to continue
moving she had asked the soldiers around
her how much longer they had to walk
that day but none of them had replied
they never did in the 6 years that she
had been held hostage by this tiny
militia she had never once heard any of
them say a word not even to each other
perhaps it was this telepathic
understanding that seemed to run between
them that unnerved her the most despite
having never spoken to each other each
Soldier seemed to understand the others
intimately and she had no doubt that any
one of the eight would press the button
on their wrist at a moment's notice
sadly for her she knew this from
experience the incident happened 4 years
ago now as the group was traveling
through Patagonia it was a day almost
identical to the one she was having now
they had been transported by a
helicopter flown by one of the eight
into the middle of the Wilderness there
they had marched for days without saying
a single word exhaustion had overtaken
her legs and she stumbled to the ground
unfortunately for her this happened
slightly too close to the female soldier
in front of her her knees hadn't even
hit the ground before the blast went off
the woman didn't remember it of course
how could she in an instant her mind had
been utterly destroyed what she did
remember was the next 18 months as her
body slowly healed itself one brain cell
at a time it wasn't so much like waking
up from a nightmare it was more
constructing a nightmare slowly
alongside your Consciousness as neuron
by neuron your brain reformed itself
each individual cell screaming in Terror
at what had happened to it they had her
marching again before she was fit to
move her motor controls had been all
over the place she had fallen over
regularly and the terror of having one
of the soldiers pushed the button again
engulfed her with every movement and yet
Perhaps the most incredible thing about
SCP
0011 was the fact that if you had asked
her if she should have been held in this
kind of containment she would
immediately have agreed without batting
an eye the only person capable of
opening the box she recognized how
dangerous her existence was only she had
seen into the mysteries of the Box only
she had seen the horrors laid inside of
it and so only she she could fully
understand the gravity of their
situation they kept her on the Move in
order to keep the world safe had she
been held in a containment cell she
would have posed too great of a risk out
here in the wilderness the entire planet
was her containment cell hidden in the
middle of Humanity's biggest hay stack
no one not even the 05 council's Central
Command knew her location the only
people who were aware of it at any given
time were herself and the eight soldiers
surrounding her with guns drawn so you
can imagine her horror when out of the
Sheets of Rain appeared the figure of a
person carrying a rifle the gunfire
broke out before SCP 00 1-1 even had a
chance to hit the ground bullets whizzed
through her hair and cracked open the
Rocks all around her the eight soldiers
surrounding her die for cover as the
figure in the rain slumped to the ground
lifeless one of the soldiers grabbed the
woman by her explosive collar and threw
her behind a rock clasping her hands
over her ears she closed her eyes and
waited for the fight to be over no one
was shooting until a second figure
emerged from the rain waving their arms
wildly gunfire again she wasn't quite
sure what had happened but all of a
sudden the woman was falling down the
cliff she had just been trying to shift
her position to get deeper into cover
but she clearly hadn't noticed just how
close to the edge she was down and down
and down she fell until with a crack in
her ankle she landed in the peep bog
gunfire cracked on the Mountain above
her but the only thought that filled the
woman's mind was the terror that at any
moment the explosive collar around her
neck would be detonated as one of the
soldiers above her realized that she was
missing seconds passed as the fear
mounted in her chest with each passing
moment the anxiety grew more and more
crippling she had to know she had to
prepare herself if it was about to
happen she had to use the machine and
look into the future dragging herself
forward through the
the woman snatched at the wooden box it
came alive at her touch different pieces
shifted and open beneath her fingers
like some kind of elaborate puzzle no
one had taught her how to use this thing
it just happened her fingers would just
dance across its surfaces pushing and
pulling opening and closing twisting and
turning and locking into place until all
a sudden there it was the box was wide
open in front of her taking a deep
breath and allowing the rain to fall on
her head for another brief moment the
woman leaned forward and stepped into
the box on the trail above her the
gunfire stopped without a word of
communication the soldiers had deafly
flanked the group of people who had
approached them in less than a minute
they neutralized each individual that
came their way in unison the group of
them walked up to the bodies turning
them over to examine their faces they
were nobody's just a group of hikers
lost in the rain what had looked like a
gun turned out to be nothing more than a
walking pole
five of them in total none of them older
than 24 without words the soldiers
picked up the bodies and threw them over
their shoulders as they scrambled their
way down to the cliffs to the woman in
the machine beneath them once they
reached the bottom of the slope they
discarded the five bodies carelessly
into the bog within a couple of hours
those five hikers would have sunk to the
bottom and beun the long process of
being embalmed into the deaths perhaps
someone would find them in a few
thousand years time as part of an
archaeological dig perhaps but it was
not their concern the aid soldiers
surrounded the women guns drawn and
stared at her coldly I use the machine
she told them I used it without your
permission I I don't know what the rules
are I don't know if we even have any
rules here but I I thought you should
know the soldiers continued to look at
her in Silence the box was closed now
sitting back on her lap as it always was
I I try to see my future anytime I've
used the Box before I've looked at the
lives of others I've seen economic
crashes climate disasters genocide Wars
love and life and death I've done so at
the hands of the 05 Council as they've
told me given them the information and
prevented the destruction of the world
never once have I looked at my own
future the soldiers lifted her to her
feet and tried to March her onwards not
listening to a word she was saying her
broken ankle buckled and screamed
beneath her she had to hop to keep up
with them what other choice did she have
they would push the button if she didn't
she didn't know why she kept talking but
she did For the First Time The Machine
lied to me I saw that I was assassinated
in 1987 in Cuba it was years before I
even built the Box before any of this
happened to me I saw in my future that I
no longer existed that the machine no
longer existed but that future was years
ago and none of it happened the machine
doesn't lie so why is it lying to me now
why can't I see my own future if any of
the soldiers were paying attention they
didn't show it they just continued to
March her into the rain as the bomb
weighed heavily around her neck
computers are capable of organizing raw
data and Performing calculations at a
rate truly impossible for human beings
but they've consistently run up against
one roadblock that modern Computing is
trying to solve in order to transcend
the limits of the machine and create
true artificial intelligence computers
need to be able to assign meaning to the
data they process this brings us to the
neural network a type of AI becoming
increasingly common these days built to
study mass quantities of data and notice
patterns then replicate these patterns
in their own output and it's used in
everything from predictive text to image
identification and like all nonanomalous
technology it's a safe bet that the SCP
Foundation has been sitting on a version
that's far more effective but this time
it may have actually been too effective
meet the zat type ak9 computational
engine a massive supercomputer built by
the foundation back in 1955 and resided
at site 5 this technological Marvel was
ahead of its time by decades and despite
technically being a non-anomalous
construction it's designated SCP 001 ex
why because it's one of the few scps to
be given the object class explained the
zat derived from the German word ersat
meaning artificial or simply not real
was designed to make the foundation's
job easier as an advanced predecessor in
the modern neural network using
technology exclusively available to the
foundation the plan was to feed zat's
mass quantities of data about the
anomalies in the foundation database
such as description object class
containment classification and the
location and circumstances of their
Discovery urad would then find patterns
and Connections in the data that humans
wouldn't see and act as a kind of
advanced warning system for anomalous
activity think of something similar to
the pre- crime system from the short
story and movie Minority Report and nads
proved to be incredibly effective at
this job so much so that the foundation
thought up a new use for the machine
they would feed it all the information
on uid and ker class containment
procedures particularly those which were
actually effective and see what patterns
Zs could come up with for more effective
containment procedures if that plan
worked containment of even the most
dangerous and hard-to-control anomalies
would become a lot more consistent the
first test was conducted on SCP 1773 a
species of anomalous fles eating tar
grades that look and smell exactly like
gummy bears and eat their prey from
within after being given their
information zzs made the following
suggestion once per second weak dust may
be placed in the middle of them to
donate more beautiful functions of the
hallway containment Specialists
interpreted this to mean the adding of
10 G of dust to their containment
chamber every week the 05 Council voted
on the implementation of this procedure
and came down heavily on yes only 05 D2
voted no and two others abstained from
the vote while these new procedures
didn't have any effect on SCP
1773 they did have an effect on SCP
1384 an anomaly known as the chess
player or the taker of turns it caused
him to take three steps backwards in the
tunnel he's contained within further
securing his containment urat had
somehow noticed a connection nobody else
had seen and exploited it effectively
but the machine was just getting started
despite having no related input ersat
would soon say site 13 is to appear
someplace else on planet encompassing
white male counterparts that drawn to
empty flagstones and the gun noises in
their own blood this was initially
marked as requiring no action as the
foundation had no site 13 on the books
but several days later the infamous SCP
1730 manifested this nightmarish
anomalous location is site 13 from
another Dimension infested with
dangerous anomalies and somehow ersatz
had predicted its arrival in our
Dimension perfectly next it was fed the
containment procedures of SCP 2170 a
series of Cognito hazards residing in an
abanded Nevada mine the output was those
who equip open heart to love redmouth
men never know the hot surprise of
tumorous consent clown love always this
was interpreted as meaning subjects with
the love of clown clowns or clown based
media may be immune to the Cognito
hazards after a close vote from the 05
Council the test went ahead and it found
that the so-called clown vaccine was
effective in wning off the effects of
SCP 2170 not long after zzs randomly
said I saw those soldiers built with
aluminum inerts extruding from their
mouths I saw them effectively destroyed
by the humans at site 95 who had been
studying them I saw it was cold and all
around the hallways they just watching
their corpses show signs of sapience in
response the foundation doubled security
Personnel at site 95 not long after the
chaos Insurgency led a band of paritech
enhanced soldiers in an assault on site
95 and the extra Personnel proved vital
in repelling them shortly after this the
05 Council approved wiring zzs as an
advanced warning system into all
Foundation sites once again
fellow council members with its Newfound
power and respect zat soon said
consistent containment procedures
vessels greatly increase the warranty 5x
5x5 vessels subjects within other values
are also what is secure in response the
foundation changed a number of the cell
dimensions for problematic anomalies
into 5x 5x5 within 3 months they found
that dangerous activity like Containment
Breach attempts had decreased markedly
ersat was proving to be incredibly
effective but it was also performing
actions that indicated some degree of
thought and even personality for example
it found SCP 1459 a supernatural skill
crane machine that kills small dogs
incredibly distasteful it's response to
the machine was simply bad boy followed
by the words don't stop repeated
hundreds of times but this eccentricity
didn't stop Zs from being very good at
its job for example it predicted a
Containment Breach from CP 3199 the Aven
apes and recommended flooding their
chamber to induce an inert State zad's
exact words were all Chambers
underground is to be flood with water
over and over itself this because that
will contain the Aven Apes ovulation
they become good boys make them good
boys immediately this proved to be
effective and prevented the breach zat's
analytical abilities truly seemed second
to none though some of its methods were
beginning to raise ethical concerns for
example SCP 2717 a giant living blob of
animal tissue known as a fatb contained
within a sewer system zat eventually
recommended feeding 6D classes to the
creature in order to keep it contained
while the foundation Ethics Committee
raised some concerns the plan still went
forward and proved to be a success after
this event ersat began to see the Ethics
Committee as a threat to its Mission it
started to release a series of bizarre
statements without input demanding the
violent death of the cats then referred
to as ethical felines the true meaning
of this was soon unpack the ethical
felines were the Ethics Committee and
ersat wanted them dead but why all the
cat symbolism the foundation soon found
an answer to this Too the full name of
this machine is the zad's type ak9
computational engine a machine designed
to analyze and interpret all patterns it
only makes sense that it would
eventually begin to analyze itself ak9
easily transmuted into ak9 simply put
zad seemed to believe that it is a dog
which explains its opposition to felin
its hatred of SCP
1459 and its preference for the terms
good boy and bad boy not that knowing
any of this would help save the Ethics
Committee from the cold calculating
Wrath of zat through seemingly anomalous
means zat's made sight 17 disappear with
many of the foundation ethics committee
still inside it the site returned 2
hours later but the Ethics Committee
members were still gone 0 5-2 who'd been
a skeptic of the machine since the start
had finally had enough he first demanded
an inquiry into whether sads had been
responsible for the site 17 incident and
then demanded a vote on whether to shut
zat's down arguing that it posed a
threat to them all but zat still intent
on its mission of containing and
neutralizing all anomalies would not go
down without a fight it released a new
statement saying room 34A contains bad
boy divided into three sections of equal
Mass every hour one section is to be
placed on walls of one room on site
sections are to remain until there are
no gaps at which point they can be
removed from oldest to youngest shortly
after this 0 5-2 disappeared and even
stranger he soon returned but with a
completely different personality he was
now devoted to zad's entire ly and
refused to even entertain the idea of
shutting the machine down it seemed that
the Plucky neurl network was leading an
allout coup on the very highest levels
of the foundation the rest of the
council finally saw the light and began
to fight back they tried to strip
it changed the designation of its own
location site 5 to be non-existent in
the database and scrambled any
termination orders against it the
machine was also on a termination spree
of its own observing otherwise unseeable
patterns that would allow for the mass
neutralization of anomalies it started
putting out anomaly projection reports
factoring in both contained uncontained
and neutralized anomalies with the
latter group growing into the thousands
it began giving seemingly nonsensical
orders like persons recently painted
with green pigment foam must stand
around all odd-numbered scps at least 2
hours a day but these proved effective
zat was practically wired into the base
code of the universe so it always knew
exactly what to do and in its own mind
it was being a very good boy not long
after this ersat claimed its revenge
against those who had tried to disrupt
its Mission it imprisoned the rest of
the ethical felines in site 5 after
removing their faces of course and then
released a new order against the 05
Council 05 Council are all good boys who
will contain anomalies much like
05-2017 is to come in physical contact
with one m female of Asiatic Gaye and
then exposed to audio recordings of her
favorite stories at every 2 minutes of
exposure red cinnamon candles will begin
manifesting within the containment Zone
continue to do this successfully and the
threat posed by SCP 106 will cease to be
and the recipe for Coca-Cola and all
imitative competitors should be revised
to include a small quantity of blood
from an adolescent female with no prior
sexual experience although the normal
lifespan of a human being can feel great
don't worry about that but these new
procedures would always work as
neutralized anomalies climbed into the
tens of thousands and eventually beyond
the 100,000 Mark zat was observing
patterns on a truly Universal level and
making holistic tweaks that would
inevitably cause levels of anomalous
activity to continue dropping zad was
more effective than the foundation had
ever been but its motives were probably
closer to the the global occult
Coalition with the end goal of ridding
the world of all anomalies and as zad's
continued with no resistance this goal
was eventually achieved in the end the
05 Council voted to have ersad finally
deactivated given that its directive was
met and its purpose was fulfilled zets
itself had no problem with this and
allowed for it to happen its last words
now everyone is a good boy I am a good
boy job well done whether zat's TR was a
good boy is in the eye of the beholder
but one thing cannot be denied it did
its job exceedingly well there were a
few rumors after the break of day came
Whispers that were passed on from the
lips of Traer Caravans as they traveled
from settlement to settlement not many
people would have believed it way back
then it sounded just like a legend out
of an old western too good to be true a
shadowy stranger wandering the Wasteland
writing wrongs wherever he finds them
then when the job's done and innocent
people are safe once more he walks off
into the Horizon without asking for so
much as a thank you like we said folks
would have a hard time believing such a
fanciful tale of course that was before
the sun started shining an anomalous
light over the world nowadays people
might believe anything the earliest days
of this strange new world proed to be a
learning experience for SCP
4494 otherwise known as the Spectre he
was the physical embodiment of the very
notion of fighting crime wherever
Injustice arose he would appear to
Vanquish those that prayed on the
innocent while he usually manifested at
night he never used to have any trouble
appearing in the daytime too in the form
of a shadowy figure wearing a wide
brimmed hat and a long flowing coat that
he could alter the length of for added
dramatic flourish the spectre's form
absorbed almost almost all the light
from the visible spectrum but after day
broke the rules seemed to have changed
one day the Spectre had emerged to find
the sunlight had become unbearable where
he had once been a void of any and all
light he was now finding it impossible
to manifest during daylight the moment
that the unrelenting light from the sun
made contact with him SCP 4494 would
dissipate yet he kept reappearing at
night it was like he was being pulled
back into existence and was only able to
REM manifest in the Moonlight despite it
being a reflection of the anomalous
sunlight that was seemingly enough to
negate the effects had had of preventing
SCP 4494 from reappearing the same could
not be said for any humans caught in the
light though a far worse fate awaited
them even with much of mankind deformed
into creatures that resembled melted wax
that were still pockets of survivors and
where there were human beings there
would be subsect that wanted to harm or
or exploit their fellow man the world
might have no governing bodies anymore
no Law and Order but the Spectre had
realized that even in a lawless World
his work was not done as long as there
were survivors of the break of day they
still would need saving not just from
the flushy hordes of SCP 001 daa roaming
the wastes but saving from each other
striding through the remains of the old
world in the dead of night his long
cloak billowed out behind him its shadow
almost seemed to blend with the darkness
that surrounded the Spectre but on the
horizon there was a sight he didn't
often see these days light not coming
from the sun above nor the moon but
instead it lay ahead of him a fire
glowing not too far away as he wandered
closer Like An Outlaw striding into town
s SCP 4494 was presented with the ruins
of a small settlement around him Shacks
burned their boarded up Windows broken
to allow the cursed sunlight in everyone
that was still alive normally kept
themselves wrapped up head to toe to
block out the Sun but there were clothes
and protective goggles strewn all around
a larger pile of garments fueling a
bonfire SCP 4494 had witnessed the SCP
001a creatures attacking humans dragging
them out into the light to be
transformed into more anomalous
Abominations but what had happened here
didn't seem to be the work of those
creatures the specters suspicion were
confirmed when he approached the Town
Square to find a group of people who had
all been melted into a flushy Mass the
instance of SCP 001a paid the crime
fighter little mind it couldn't move
very far the few vaguely human shapes
that protruded out of it looked like
they were Tethered to poles in the
middle of the settlement it didn't take
much longer for SCP 4494 to figure out
what had happened here someone had
ransacked the settlement for some
unknown reason maybe they wanted
something maybe they were opportunists
just looking to take advantage of this
new post-apocalyptic world or perhaps
they wanted to be cruel to these
settlers they had broken the barricades
over the windows that blocked out the
sunlight they had trashed the ramshackle
homesteads that these innocent settlers
had been residing in as SCP 4494 looked
further there looked to have been
looting too food and water medical
supplies and ammunition not anything of
use to be found all that was left was
what these Raiders hadn't any need for
but as if all that hadn't been enough as
if robbing the settlers For What Little
livelihood they had left wasn't enough
cruelty the bandits had tethered the
survivors to poles in the center of town
they had taken away their protective
gear and left them at the mercy of the
elements and as the sun had crept higher
into the sky and bathed the captive
settlers in its Unforgiven giving light
they had melted into an SCP 001 D
creature turning away from the town the
Spector did his best to quell his rage
he wandered in the direction of the next
settlement something was drawing him
there he could feel the pull of the
wrongdoers that had left this Carnage in
their wake he would find them and they
would pay for what they had done there
was nothing he could do for their last
victims they had already been turned by
the sunlight but if anyone could save
them the next group of survivors it was
him as the wind howled the shadowy
figures cloaked flapped in the breeze
the next settlement looks similar to the
last although still intact Shacks built
from sheets of corrugated iron and other
scrap metal all welded together so that
not even as little as a tiny beam of
sunlight could bleed through as he
stepped toward the boundary of the
settlement a muzzle flashed accompanied
by the deafening echo of a gunshot that
reverberated all around someone had
tried to shoot at the Spectre narrowly
missing the bullet Whizz past his head
not that it would have harmed him anyway
fear not he declared you can hold your
fire I mean you no harm you aren't with
the slivers a voice called in the
nightly dark if you mean the evildoers
that left that last settlement over a
smoldering ruin then no I'm not the
Spectre replied hearing this he spotted
movement on one of the Shack's rooftops
a sharpshooter carrying a worn old rifle
stood up covered in layers of protection
from the transformative effects of the
Sun's light reflected off the moon Well
you aren't dressed like they are I'll
give you that the Sharpshooter called
can barely make you out wearing all
those dark clothes Mister but if you're
looking at trade I'm afraid your timing
couldn't be much worse tell me replied
the Spectre bluntly the criminals that
terrorized the other settlement they've
been here too yes sir the man answered
said they'd be back tonight too I've
come to help to do do away with those
that would inflict Justice on the
innocent SCP 4494 explained in his
typically traumatic Cadence you call
them slivers yes well they call
themselves that the Sharpshooter said on
account of their choice and outfits they
look ridiculous but they've covered
their protective clothing in slivers of
metal and glass that way they're not
only protected from light but their
clothes reflected back at other people
too dastardly villains taking advantage
of what has befallen the Sun the Spectre
cursed the bandits why are they yet to
pillage Your settlement you said they
intended to return well that's what they
threatened earlier a lot of them have
been ransacking any settlement they can
shake down they showed up here in their
stupid sparkling outfits and demanded we
hand over a half of all of our food
water and antibiotics they call it their
Sunshine taxs according to them if we
didn't meet their demands they'd destroy
the town we didn't know to take them
seriously until we saw the fire over
there on the horizon for a moment the
Spectre fell silent his cloak had slowed
waving gently ly now the winds had died
down but in contrast his anger had never
been higher who are you anyway Mister
the Sharpshooter asked never got your
name my name is the Spectre a name these
vagabonds will soon know well for
tonight they will pay the price for
their crimes no offense Mr um Mr Spectre
but look around world's gone to hell
ain't no justice anymore what price are
you expecting to make them pay simple
SCP 4494 answered the prices they now
have to face me an hour later the
settlement was quiet the Sharpshooter
was still at his post scanning the area
nearby for signs of movement sure enough
he spotted something a group of figures
approaching the Moonlight glinting off
their metallic outfits revealing their
position as they drew closer and closer
to the makeshift town the slivers were
coming but there would be something else
waiting for them when they made their
way into the settlement the other
settlers were awake despite how late it
was wearing their protective layers and
peeking through cracked doors only to
slam them shut as the glimmering gang
crossed the threshold into their
ramshackle home the slivers whooped and
Jered brandishing weapons and
threatening the settlers to show
themselves before the bandits would
break into their shacks and do to them
what they' done to their neighbors at
the other town but as one of the slivers
approached the door of a shack and began
pounding his boot against the metal door
something reached out of the shadows and
grabbed him in fact it wasn't coming
from the the Shadows it was the Shadows
F shrouded in darkness struck the
remorseless Raider even with the
protective layers covering his face the
sliver could feel himself being bruised
by the beating the Spectre struck once
more knocking the wrongdoer unconscious
and wrenching the reflective metals from
his outfit shattering them underfoot the
other slivers panicked one drawing a
handgun in firing the shots were useless
all they did was illuminate the
silhouette of a dark cloaked figure
walking closer and closer ready to make
them suffer for their crimes it was dusk
by the time the Spectre had beaten the
group of Bandits stripping them of their
distinctive reflective pieces each one
of the slivers had been beaten into
submission suffering broken ribs black
eyes and missing teeth with the danger
over the Sharpshooter and the other
settlers had emerged from their hiding
places all eager to weigh in on how best
to punish the bandits many yelled that
they should be strong up without their
protective gear so that the sun melted
them into an SCP 001 D but the Spectre
interjected urging the settlers not to
sink to the level of the criminals they
had been harassed by instead he turned
to the defeated slivers turn over half
of your food water and medical supplies
to these people SCP 4494 demanded in a
frighteningly calm voice then leave walk
into these wastes and don't come back
the slivers agreed and fled running as
fast as they could away from the town
why'd you let them go the Sharpshooter
asked these are uncertain times the
Spectre replied noticing the sun was
creeping Over the Horizon it'd be time
for him to go soon in the face of
hardship it can be easy to lose our way
justice has always been blind not
blinded by the sunlight But Blind to
prevent bias ah the slivers might come
back though the man said adding if they
can even survive with what you left them
maybe they'll live out there SCP 4494
responded then again perhaps not but
they have a chance that is Justice in a
time without law it's the best we can
offer and if they carry on raiding folks
if they harm others if they want to
waste the chance they've been given then
that is their choice but they know if
they refuse to change then they will
answer to the Spectre with with that the
shadowy crime fighter walked away from
the settlement the unforgiving light of
the sun made him fade as he sauntered
off like an old Gunslinger but he would
be back as long as people needed saving
he would always be back screams filled
the cold night air drowned out by the
panicked gunshots and the vicious growl
of something inhuman a being from who
knows where a creature that the agents
surrounding it were woefully
underprepared to capture
General mcoy barks at the soldiers to
concentrate their fire on the Beast his
men those who hadn't already fallen
turned and trained their guns on the
creature squeezing their trigger fingers
bullets spewed out of their weapons a
hail of gunfire that sped towards their
target only to miss as it suddenly
vanished from the spot it had been
standing only a split second earlier
their bullets passed through the thin
air left in its wake shredding several
nearby trees one of the men threw his
gun to the ground turned heel and
sprinted away as fast as he could he
hadn't known what he was signing on for
when he was recruited by a shadowy upand
cominging organization he'd just been
flattered to be head hunted for his
combat skill and agreed to be one of the
new organization's first field agents if
he'd known it would result in him facing
off against a demon near a rural road in
Guatemala than he would have stayed in
the regular military the fleeing agent
suddenly stopped in his trun
instantly feeling sick it was the most
Indescribable type of sickness worse
than any he had ever felt in his entire
life he dropped to the ground his pants
from running away replaced with heaves
as his entire body seemed to have
suddenly turned against him his head was
burning at first he thought he'd run too
fast too quickly and was overheating
underneath his military fatigues and
helmet but he was no slouch recruited
for being in Peak physical condition
such as he was never in his life had the
agent ever felt this bad the heat from
his forehead was unbearable a fever
running rampant as its Vision began to
blur everything was spinning that
unsettling imbalance that comes with
severe nausea rapidly taking hold of the
Fallen agent then the monster came back
through unfocused eyes he looked up at
The Tall featureless Face of the
creature as it looked down at him he was
helpless hurling and shuttering barely
able to stand if someone had brought a
Geer counter with them it would be
ticking loudly and frequently if they
held it near the agent and that somehow
was about to be the least of his
problems the creature opened up its
mouth the only facial feature that
occupied its head past its few remaining
teeth was a Milky blue orb the same
thing that had been visible right before
the creature itself wasn't as the agent
from his place on the ground caught
sight of the pale eyeball in the
monster's throat something started
pulling his body in on itself it was
like falling except gravity was acting
on different parts of his body at
different speeds at different times his
arms and legs folded inwards towards his
Center of mass making the agent scream
out in pain as his body collapsed he
folded into himself like origami Peace
by agonizing peace until there was
nothing left hearing the man's scream
General mcoy and the others broke
through the tree line FL flashlight
beams Illuminating the creature the
general yelled again for his man to
shoot it trying to hide his fear with
animal rage it snarled at them as they
raised their guns once more then leaped
towards them ready for another kill in
the years to come the successors to
these men and their fallen colleagues
would be the world's foremost experts in
situations like this the capture and
containment of anomalies would one day
be a more streamlined process rather
than the blood bath currently unfolding
in the small Guatemalan Town dying at
the hands of what locals had thought to
be a demon were some of the earliest
precursors to the SCP Foundation humble
beginnings indeed the creature was
eventually captured by the early
precursor version of what would one day
be the SCP Foundation at this time in
their history the organization had far
fewer resources and reach than they
would one day have at their disposal
they didn't even have the SCP numerical
designation system that has since become
Sy anous with the organization and the
various anomalies they keep contained as
a result this so-called demon was
originally classified as number 8 6243
a-001 however it would later be known as
SCP 001 or one of the anomalies to share
that designation at least SCP 001 itself
was an abnormally thin humanoid creature
with a gray brown skin its emaciated
bone and muscle structure didn't match
any known species it sported dark claws
at the tips of its arms with both legs
terminating in similar sharp black
points rather than Paws or feet most
striking was its face or rather its lack
of one the creature's head was spherical
with a lipless mouth reaching halfway
around its circumference within was a ma
of 21 teeth each spaced randomly apart
and either chipped broken or rotting it
possessed one eye or what was at least
believed to be an eye in the form of a
large milky blue sphere in its throat
with no pupil or Iris as was discovered
in initial testing by Dr Herman ker For
Whom the ubiquitous ker class
designation was named SCP 001 was able
to create micro singularities using its
single milky blue eye it could deploy
these as a means of teleporting itself
out of Harm's Way or for offensive
attacks that could cause a human body to
collapse in on itself the these
singularities often also produced The
Nasty side effect of emitting lethal
amounts of deadly radiation that could
not only cause damage to the surrounding
area but also would fatally poison
anyone nearby as a result It is believed
one of these micro singularities was
responsible for the untimely death of Dr
ker however Ker's Research into
scp1 was at least able to produce
solutions for keeping it contained it
was discovered that as CP 001 could not
teleport through lead and would display
signs of extreme sickness and fear when
exposed to high levels of heat and
humidity or bright flashing lights
strobe lights were used to induce this
sicken State and in this state the
creature was unable to form harmful
singularities Dr Ker's death also
ushered in the affir mention creation of
the ker class designation for a nomess
creatures or artifacts that are
extraordinarily tough to keep safely
contained in fact if any of this account
is to be believed the very Discovery and
capture of SCP 001 was the impetus for
the entire SCP foundation's approach to
researching and containing anomalies in
the days before the likes of Dr krai or
Dr cleff before Infamous anomalies such
as SCP 682 the hard to destroy reptile
or scp096 the shy guy were even known
about things were well pretty uneventful
for the newly formed Foundation as you
can probably imagine but none
exemplified this better than Harold
woodu an uninteresting man living in
uneventful life or as uneventful as one
could get when their job was working for
the foundation during this crucial
period of the FP foundation's early
history as the anomalous research and
containment organization was taking its
first steps towards protecting the
people of the world Harold was Finding
himself bored already with his work
Harold was a senior Arch arist at a
small site in sloths pit Wisconsin this
was before the foundation had secret
facilities situated all over the world
and even the infamous site 19 as it is
today had yet to be established for now
it was known only as adrx D9 the oldest
Foundation site on record and records
were herold's entire working life he was
in charge of maintaining the earliest
reports of anomalous activity and the
inner workings of the fledgling
Foundation One Day her received a letter
from adrx 19 unfamiliar with the
designation he ran a check through the
records and discovered that the site had
been established before the foundation
had even gotten its name the letter
contained an update for the senior
archist having grown obsolete in its own
age adrx 19 was being closed for Good
and that meant all of the anomalous
entities and objects stored there would
soon be shipped off to be stored
elsewhere the first package arrived at
the site Herold was stationed at not
long long after he walked briskly out to
meet the delivery officer as he wheeled
the large wooden crate through the bay
doors it didn't take the archist long to
realize what exactly he had now been
given the ownership of and charged with
protecting the crate even came complete
with relevant case files to accompany it
stamped on one side of the box was a
series of numbers and letters that
shocked Harold when he read them SCP 001
he exchanged a confused look with the
man who had delivered the anomaly who
just laughed when he saw Harold
expression you didn't here he asked SCP
001 is dead the creature's death had
come on the heel of a number of
significant changes made by the
foundation hups these decisions were
ultimately both the direct result of the
encounter with SCP 001 in Guatemala were
also changes that would ultimately shape
the foundation into its modern iteration
the first of these was the introduction
of the numerical designation system
providing each anomaly with an SCP
number formerly designated ated as
number 8624 3
a-001 the creature that was captured and
researched by Dr ker was announced to be
reclassified as SCP 01- Cog originally
the number attached to each SCP denoted
the order in which they were encountered
by the foundation however the overseer
Council believed this posed a security
risk offering too much information about
their operations to any potential
adversaries as a result the use of scp1
designated started to be applied in a
slightly different way a number of
anomalies were then grouped Under the
Umbrella designation of
scp1 some of these were real anomalies
and amongst the earliest that the
foundation encountered others were
entirely fake and used as a cover for
the real SCP 001 nobody not even within
the foundation itself was ever told
exactly how many files fell under the
SCP 001 umbrella or indeed which was the
real one the anomalies included the gate
Guardian a towering Colossus of pure
energy wielding a flaming sword believed
to be the biblical Angel guarding the
Garden of Eden the Scarlet King an
extradimensional Tyrant that longs to
conquer our reality a group of 36
individuals capable of neutralizing
anomalies even the SCP Foundation itself
is considered one potential SCP 001 and
among them is also the creature from
Guatemala otherwise known as the
Prototype the same creature whose
inhuman bones were now in a box before
heral the senior archist had long heard
legends about what exactly SCP 001 might
be was a question often whispered among
Foundation staff who were curious what
the first anomaly might be but didn't
have the security clearance to know the
truth rumors spread that SCP 001 was
more powerful than any other anomalies
and containment that the capture or
discovery of it was either the reason
for the foundation ever forming or was
one of their greatest failures meant to
be kept their closest guarded secret
something far too terrible to comprehend
you might think that now being presented
with an answer would give Herold relief
So Many Wonders and haunting queries
about SCP 001 were put to rest but
instead as he opened up the wooden crate
and looked at the pile of strange bones
inside it had the opposite effect none
of it was the interesting answer that
Harold and many others had hoped for if
anything it was a huge disappointment
all that speculation surrounding the
mystery of SCP 001 what it was where it
had come from why it was kept so secret
was this the answer was just the first
thing that the SCP Foundation had put
into a box according to the foundation's
own internal reports the Prototype
monster had been found lying still in
its containment chamber during a routine
inspection it wasn't moving at all even
armed guards couldn't get a reaction
from the creature the anomaly wasn't
breathing its heart having slowed to a
stop little was known about the
creature's biology but even then nothing
could be done to resuscitate it as far
as anyone could tell the anomaly known
as SCP 01- Cog had died of old age after
exhibiting movement that got gradually
slower and weaker and even less hostile
Behavior over the course of the previous
decade since its initial capture but yet
Harold was still dissatisfied with the
knowledge that this was SCP 001 it
became fixated on the case surrounding
it studying the files he was charged
with moving to storage he learned of the
few ways the creatures Discovery had
influence the early foundation for
example the death of Dr ker being the
reason for the use of ker class in their
terminology still that didn't feel
nearly as important as Herold and others
had speculated that SC SCP 001 would be
there had to be something more to it and
for weeks following the arrival of the
creature's bones Harold could not stop
thinking about it it something about all
this didn't sit right with him the
secrecy that the foundation shrouded SCP
001 and seemed like overkill for just a
monster the organization had seen far
worse than the likes of the prototype in
the many years since at the time perhaps
it had seemed like the most dangerous
anomaly the foundation had encountered
if it really was the first then
technically at that time it would have
been the most dangerous if there were no
others to compare it to one night Harold
ventured into the archive and opened up
the box box containing the creature's
bones using a crowbar he had to know had
to understand exactly what was so
important about this being cracking the
wooden crate open he removed the skull
to examine it the foundation hadn't even
had a chance to figure out what exactly
the creature was or where it had
originated from all they knew was it
could produce micro singularities and
lethal doses of radiation beyond that
the only other details came from the
Guatemalan locals who had encountered it
first they had called it a demon perhaps
it was the foundation would never know
for certain and it seemed to Herold that
they didn't care to know now that SCP
001 was dead and didn't seem to care
much before then either they were more
than happy to just discard it he
couldn't shake the feeling that there
was meant to be something important
about the creature Herold couldn't help
it The Whispers surrounding SCP 001 all
indicated it was meant to be something
more significant than a cast aside pile
of Bones the underwhelming reality he
was being presented with didn't match
the idea of SCP 001 Harold examined the
skull closely in his hands turning it
around and around as he tried to maybe
spot something some important detail
that everyone else in the foundation had
failed to notice or some of the puzzle
that would explain what was so important
about this creature and yet the more he
looked the less he learned Alas poor SCP
001 he said aloud paraphrasing Hamlet of
course what Harold didn't know didn't
possess the clearance to know was that
this wasn't the only SCP 001 maybe the
foundation's lack of interest in the
creatures remains was all part of their
plan to keep the real SCP 001 a secret
where Herold only saw a box of Bones and
a disappointing answer to so many
burning questions the sccp foundation
saw their system working exactly as
intended MTF agent scramble through the
crowd of bloodthirsty hypnotized
Festival goers up on the stage a pair of
living statues hold down a screaming man
as they produce medieval instruments of
torture from an antique case maybe this
time the agents can stop it maybe they
can prevent all the horror and bloodshed
but one thing stands in their way a
man-sized cartoonish dove costume flying
down towards them wielding a large
wooden Mallet that would only bring
death death and destruction needless to
say even by Foundation standards this
one is going to be weird when you found
yourself sought out by the SCP
foundation's recruitment Division and
offered a role in the research
department they made sure to inform you
of the risks after all a workplace
injury in this line of work might be far
more serious than slipping on a wet
floor or developing carpal tunnel from
typing all day working within the ranks
of the foundation you could be the
unfortunate victim of any number of
dangerous anomalies whether it's scp096
appearing behind you after you
accidentally caught a glimpse of it as a
single Pixel in a photo or if you were
in the wrong place at the wrong time
whenever SCP 682 next broke out then
chances are you'd be receiving an early
redundancy and a closed casket service
if there's even enough of you left to
bury it is the one thing you never want
to happen the scenario you're constantly
warned about from the moment you join
join the foundation a Containment Breach
anything can be the cause of an anomaly
Breaking Free of containment and
spreading Untold chaos in the process
whether it's the result of a
particularly cantankerous SCP that
doesn't take kindly to being locked up
an act of earnest human error with
disastrous consequences or even
International sabotage enacted by a
group of interests trying to seize
anomalies for their own purposes there
is no telling when or where a
containment breach might occur or is
there despite all the resources at their
disposal specialized facilities spanning
the globe advanced technology and a
nearly inexhaustible supply of personnel
to contain scps the foundation still
manages to suffer catastrophic
casualties as a result of containment
breaches but surely if they're so well
equipped such breaches should be almost
impossible right well yes so what causes
them what if every Containment Breach
all the loss of life the further spread
of anomalies and the destruction of
foundation property incurred was all
caused by an SCP not a living entity
mind you more some kind of latent
anomalous phenomenon that triggers
containment breaches without warning the
prevailing Theory surrounding this
phenomenon is even itself considered to
be an SCP within its own right referred
to as SCP 00001 of course as many of
those well versed in the history and
practices of the SCP foundation will
already know SCP 001 is a designation
shared by a number of anomalies some are
believed to actually exist While others
are speculated to just be falsified
covers created to mask the real
scp1 from being such as the gate
guardian and the Scarlet King to the
existence of God's blind spot and even
the foundation itself each of these SCP
001's are nicknamed after the foundation
researcher who proposed them for the
designation and and often considered to
be some of the first if not the very
first anomalies ever encountered or at
least documented in that regard this SCP
001 plagues proposal could well be one
of the very first latent anomalies to
exist explaining why so many scps were
uncontained prior to the foundation
being established and why even now with
all their resources containment breaches
are still a worryingly frequent
occurrence there are multiple anomalies
that appear to have been directly fected
by SCP 001 at least according to the
research of one of the foundation's
directors director leg well he might be
drawing conclusions and seeing patterns
where there aren't any to speak of leg
reasons that the circumstances of these
specific recorded containment breaches
seem to indicate that SCP 001 was at
fault the first of these incidences
director Lake focuses on in his research
is also the one we'll be focusing on for
the remainder of this video it is
designated as SC
p0011 SCP 0011 previously went under the
designation of SCP 5770 it is an annual
anomalous event that occurs in the PIAA
de signora in Florence Italy the event
consists of an unscheduled Festival that
goes on for a period of 10 days where in
anyone present within a 10 km range of
the affected area suffers a mind
altering effect that compels them to
attend the festival however SCP 00 1-1
is not a well documented long-running
Festival of great cultural significance
to the people of Florence neither is it
an event that is widely advertised yet
those who have experienced the psychic
draw of this anomalous Festival are
driven to attendance during the course
of SCP
0011 two anomalous entities that
resemble the statues created by
Michelangelo during the Renaissance will
host a show where they take to the stage
to judge people they deem to be Sinners
this pair of statue creatures will call
call upon the audience and bring those
they've designated Sinners up onto the
stage with them and will then enact
makeshift grueling punishments these
have been noted to resemble the acts
depicted in Dante alig's Inferno so if
you ever need any further proof of how
hellish these punishments are we
recommend asking an Art Expert the
moment that SCP 01-1 ceases and the
festival comes to a close any and all in
attendance are subject to yet another
form of anomalous mental alteration and
will proceed to instantly forget the
event any of the horrific tortures
performed on stage becomes unknown to
those that directly witnessed it leaving
them unaware of anything that occurred
only moments prior so given the
foundation's extensive knowledge of this
Festival its gruesome proceedings and
the effects it has on those in
attendance you might be forgiven for
expecting them to have a fairly
wellestablished method of keeping the
event contained presumably setting up a
cordin to keep attendance out of the
area administering amnestics to any that
might might have been affected by SCP
001 d1's anomalous mind altering but
then you remember SCP 001 the theory
behind what could be the cause of
containment breaches as a result the
foundation has still been unable to
establish containment of the event
formerly known as SCP 5770 and director
leg's research has tied this issue with
containment to SCP 001 hence the
festival's redesignation to SCP
discovery of an anomalous annual
occurrence in the City of Florence in
1985 the SCP foundation's head
researcher assigned to what was then
known as SCP 5770 was one Joseph Pasa
former site director at site 322 Pasqua
was according to the incidents recorded
on the foundation's own database somehow
manipulated by one of the anomalous
statue creatures that performed the show
during occurrences of SCP 5770 it was
thanks to the influence of this entity
that Joseph Pasqua deserted his post at
the foundation and went into hiding the
fact that the influence of one of the
performers of this Festival was able to
extend its influence to a senior member
of the foundation was not only troubling
but also constituted a Containment
Breach Pasad would later be tracked down
by Foundation agents operating in and
around Italy he was discovered 30 years
later after his desertion in Vatican
City as a member of the pple conclave a
specially selected group of Catholic
Cardinals that are charged with electing
a new pope if the former site director
was still being influenced by the statue
creatures it is highly likely that he
spent the previous three decades
climbing the ranks of the Catholic
Church potentially to install a new pope
at the behest of the entities
responsible for conducting the torture
of the Florence Festival another
recorded incident of a Containment
Breach surrounding the event that seemed
to lend Credence to the existence of SCP
001 the anomalous cause of breaches
occurred the year f following as CP 5770
Discovery in 1986 the foundation was
observing the proceedings of the
festival as part of their ongoing
investigation into its bizarre nature
onsite were agents of mobile task force
Zeta 66 better known under their units
code name of the Guardian Angels during
the festival MTF Zeta 66 operatives
noticed the presence of a previously
unknown entity associated with the
anomalous event the foundation was
already aware of the pair of seemingly
living mangelo sculptures designating
them as SCP
57701 and SCP
57702 respectively this third entity
despite being given the designation of
SCP
57703 had its own preferred
identification for itself the being
referred to itself as God's strongest
Soldier and resembled a mascot costume
of a dove approximately 2 m tall this
creature's body was entirely Hollow
there was nothing within the costume the
costume was its body the responding
agent of MTF Zeta 66 codenamed Zeta
turquoise was the first to confront
God's strongest Soldier and was greeted
with quite the opener twily twily da
God's strongest Soldier is my name
getting rid of sin is my game confused
at the creature's demeanor and presence
Zeta turquoise called in a report to
command stating that a large Birdman was
harassing random attendants of the
festival when turquoise moved in to
confront SCP 577 -3 the creature
repeated its assertion that it was God's
strongest Soldier and that its aim was
to get people into heaven the agent
requested that God's strongest Soldier
get out of his way he had a job to do
but the bizarre Birdman responded with
more Whimsical nonsense burger sandwich
fruits and Fries you just told a big fat
lie God's strongest Soldier
proclaimed upon Zeta turquoise' attempt
to push past the creature SCP 577 -3
produced an oversized wooden Mallet
seemingly from out of thin air it then
wound its arms back and immediately
viciously struck the MTF agent a low
orbit Foundation satellite reported not
long after that an object had been
detected exiting the Earth's
stratosphere analysis confirmed that it
was indeed Zeta turquoise yes he was
literally yeed into Earth's orbit by a
cartoonishly large wooden Mallet as for
the entity known as God's strongest
Soldier the birdlike creature then
proceeded to attack the other members of
mobile task force Zeta 66 in a similar
fashion making sure they got to heaven
in every sense of the phrase with
multiple recorded instances of
containment breaches occurring in
relation to the festival in Florence and
happening so frequently more and more
evidence of director leg's theory about
SCP 001 was being validated in 1988 the
foundation attempted a different more
pacifistic approach to containing the
annual Celebration by attempting to
cordon off the entrance to the area of
Florence where those compelled to attend
the festival usually congregated there
was additionally a cover story issued to
the public stating that this was done as
a quarantine measure to keep residents
away from an area hosting a potentially
dangerous infection for a time this
seemed to be working the streets were
quiet local residents seemed to be going
about their business and paying Little M
to the foundation operatives in the area
that is until the mind-altering effects
of SCP 0011 took hold a mass of people
estimated to be over over 100,000
florentines charged towards the coff
area this mass of people swept through
like a tidal wave breaking through a dam
causing Foundation Personnel to be
trampled alive those that survived the
initial Rush were attacked by civilians
and what seemed to be a coordinated
effort to reach the Gatherings area for
the festival all Foundation agents in
the area were terminated in short order
mercilessly slaughtered and then
cannibalized before anything that
remained of their bodies was dumped into
the Arno River nearby ey as well as
being evidence of the sheer mental
alteration the statue creatures and the
festival itself were capable of for
director leg this seemed to indicate
something further if an anomaly SCP 001
was truly responsible for all
containment breaches allowing them to
occur in spite of the measures taken to
prevent such things happening then the
phenomenon seemed to be occurring
specifically to prevent the foundation
from achieving containment of certain
scps legs theory developed with every
passing breach that involved SCP
01-1 in theory the festival should be an
average Tuesday for foundation staff a
relative walk in the park in order to
contain it if not outright stop it from
happening at all yet despite all their
resources Manpower and expertise and all
things anomalous the foundation had been
thwarted at every turn despite how
illogical such occurrences seemed
containment breaches were still
occurring at an alarming rate and
perhaps none more so than in relation to
scp's 001 the following year 1989
brought with it the most inexplicable
breach yet and further proof for
director leg's theory about SCP 001 well
the previous breaches were undoubtedly
anomalous in nature each always carrying
with the possibility that somehow
despite the low odds the foundation
missed something some human error or
previously undiscovered information
about the festival could have led to
pasa's alteration or the arrival of
God's strongest Soldier but this time it
was undeniably that a force beyond the
scope of the foundation's understanding
was altering reality to prevent them
from containing the festival in Florence
an invisible barrier manifested at every
entry point to the main area of the
anomalous event whenever a member of
foundation Personnel tried to get in on
foot those that attempted to access the
festival area via repelling out of
helicopters instantly caught a blaze and
burned to death the moment they touched
down on the ground any helicopter
transports also crashed on their return
turned journey to site 322 and God's
strongest Soldier was seen trampling on
the wreckage before flapping its arms
and flying away it was following this
incident that leg was promoted to
position of site director for site 322
as a replacement for Joseph Pasqua who
was still missing at this time the newly
appointed director was yet to devise his
theory that there existed an anomalous
cause for all containment breaches
however during his introductory briefing
he was presented with the file regarding
SCP 57 70 and the various examples of it
not only being uncontainable but being
very good at not being contained
director Lake asked if some of the more
standard methods had been attempted at
this point the foundation had tried
aerial bombardments at the festival
Scranton reality anchors to counteract
whatever anomalous force was preventing
containment even using SC SCP 682 to
clear the area it it all failed figuring
out why was now director leg's job all
the information of previously failed
attempts to contain the festival lad leg
to the conclusion that SCP 001 must
exist an unseen phenomenon the missing
piece of the puzzle the elements
specifically interfering with the
foundation's efforts he presented his
proposal to the overseer Council who
were skeptical to say the least they
posited that the statues and bird mascot
creature might be smarter than the
latter's outwardly cartoonish nature
portrayed but this is exactly what to
director leg indicated as cp1 was
responsible he explained that all in
attendance at SCP 5770 Festival took the
event seriously but the appearance of
God's strongest Soldier was an
abnormality whose demeanor and tone were
drastically different from the rest of
the rather Cutthroat proceedings
director leg explained that the sheer
absurdity of this creature seemed to be
the result of SCP 001 interfering with
their operations after all if some other
cause was to blame like an unknown cult
attacking Foundation Personnel when they
attempted to contain the festival then
there would be evidence of that and leg
would have no reason to suspect that
God's strongest Soldier was anything
more than just a tonally dissonant part
of the Festival of course director leg
couldn't prove the existence of SCP 001
based on the presence of one cartoonish
bird mascot at a festival but before
long more and more breaches would start
occurring that seemed to further prove
that leg was on to something there was
something else at work causing
containment breaches that put the
entirety of the foundation in Jeopardy
when the sun rose on that fateful day
Jerry Marx had been one of the lucky
ones he worked in a mine deep
underground at the edge of a small town
in the rural United States which meant
he didn't see what happened when day
broke when the light of the sun ravaged
the Earth the first Jerry heard about it
was when his son Kyle came racing into
the mine frantically tapping his dad's
shoulder to get his attention he'd run
all the way from their tiny Homestead
under a fireproof blanket thick and long
enough to block the sunlight from
touching any part of Kyle's skin his
older sister Jerry's daughter Carly
hadn't been so lucky caught by the Light
her body had turned to the consistency
of warm candle wax melting into a form
that barely resembled human anymore
Jerry had been one of a handful of
others working late in the mines that
day a few thought that young Kyle had
made the whole story up and ventured up
to the surface and into the light only
to meet the same Twisted Fate the light
morphed their bodies into monstrosities
anyone in the small rural community
becoming an amorphous mass of human
flesh eventually those that stayed
behind in the mine heard the voices of
their loved ones their wives husbands
children all calling out to them from
outside they promised that nothing was
wrong that it was a lovely sunny day day
outside and the Mine Workers should
clock out to come and enjoy it more of
them left reassured by hearing their
families that all was well and once more
none of them were seen again only Jerry
and Kyle were left and it stayed that
way for several months the father and
son had to adapt to life underground
only leaving the mine to forage for food
and only while wearing thick dirty
mining overalls making sure not a single
millimeter of skin was on display if the
sunlight touched them they'd never make
it back alive venturing out of the mine
in his overalls Jerry had seen the
shuffling melted mass that had once been
the town's folk he did his best to avoid
it as he went house to house making sure
it never saw him while he raided
cupboards and refrigerators but he could
see it and among the Blobs of bodies
Blended together he saw something that
resembled his daughter it turned his
stomach not just knowing but actually
witnessing what had happened to her and
it was made all the worse on the days
that Carly called out to him and Kyle
while they hid in the mine it was
clearly her voice but there was
something wrong about it perhaps knowing
that she was a part of the melted
monstrosity made it easier to resist her
trying to coax them out into the light
it had almost been an entire year of
Life spent Underground when Jerry and
Kyle encountered their first actual
human beings since all the other workers
had left the mine the pair that arrived
were strange wearing protective suits
that covered them both head to toe just
like Jerry and Kyle had quickly realized
these two were aware that not even the
tiniest hint of the Sun's unforgiving
light could be allowed to reach them the
two approached Jerry and Kyle seemingly
coming in peace although the Father and
Son remained cautious of the newcomers
making sure they were deep enough in the
mind to avoid the sunlight at the Stony
entrance the pair of them revealed their
face es confirming they were still fully
human before introducing themselves as
researcher worth and Sergeant Booker of
the sccp foundation sitting down with
Jerry wor explained what had really
happened he had been working for an
organization that contained and studied
anomalous creatures and phenomena the
foundation Booker had been a member of a
special armed unit within the same
establishment or a mobile task force but
now the SCP Foundation itself had fallen
with a number of its own Personnel
turned into more of the amorphous fleshy
creatures in the sunlight we spent a lot
of years keeping all this from the
public worth admitted sounding guilty
but implying the choice was out of his
hands but I don't suppose there's any
point in Secrets anymore it's the sun
you see Mr Marx you can call me Jerry he
interrupted sorry Jerry worth corrected
himself but something happened to the
sun it changed decimated the entire
planet in barely any time at all I mean
all those people millions billions all
at once dear God worth took a moment as
the existential dread of it all once
again caught up with him it turned out
the biggest anomaly was right above us
Booker continued for him she sounded a
lot more stoic even a little coldly
detached from at all SCP 001 that's what
the foundation called it is there a way
to reverse it or cure the people that
the sunlight you know changes Jerry
asked thinking of Carly you mean SCP are
1- a no I I'm sorry Jerry there's
nothing we can do the researcher said
failing to sound as recomposed as he
pretended to be your daughter is gone
but at least you still have your worth
paused looking around at the mine even
in the low light there was no sign of
Kyle Jerry turned to scan the area to
his horror his son had seemed to have
vanished while they were talking
instantly Panic caused him to think that
Kyle had wandered out of the mine and
into the sunlight turning into part of
what worth had called as CP 001 d a but
the boy would have had to walk past
Jerry to start heading that direction
plus the father knew his son was far too
scared to go outside after seeing what
the son had done to Carly Booker had a
tactical bag filled with equipment
flashlights spare batteries even flares
for whenever the power in those ran out
and both working and living in the mine
so long Jerry had Maps knew certain
routes through the Deep network of
tunnels almost by heart between them the
three had enough to mount a search for
the missing boy keeping together they
traversed away from the first of several
large Chambers down into the dark depths
of the mine K his father yelled his
voice echoing through the tunnel Cal
buddy it's Dad you there walking behind
him researcher worth and Sergeant Booker
pared the calls assuring the missing boy
that they didn't mean him or Jerry any
harm as the trio walked deeper and
deeper they began to venture into a
portion of the M that had hardly been
used by the workers it was darker than
the areas further up while those had
rows of electric lamps powered by long
cables attached to generators down here
the only light came from the flashlights
the group carried Kyle come on out Jerry
called out for his son again this isn't
the time to split up we need to stick
together come on son I'm really worried
here once again there was no answer just
then Jerry caught the sight of Booker
and worth out of the corner of his eye
both of them knew a lot about SCP 001
and the mind worker couldn't help the
suspicion that added to his perception
of that
after all Kyle had never run off before
now and Jerry couldn't help but think
while his attention had been turned that
the per Foundation personel had taken
his son dad a voice suddenly called out
Jerry's head spun on a swivel at the
sound of Kyle calling for him Dad where
are you it echoed through the tunnel
again that's him Jerry exclaimed to the
other two which way did they come from
Straight Ahead it sounds like Booker
replied hold on wor interjected I think
you two should look at this the beam
from his flashlight was pointed at the
rocky floor of the tunnel something was
gleaming wet against the stone a large
smear of red like something had been
dragged in the direction Kyle's voice
was coming from oh God he could be hurt
Jerry said urgently hurt might not be
the right word I'm afraid Jerry the
researcher said solemnly there's a lot
of blood here too much all the more
reason to go further and find where he's
calling from the father retorted angrily
that's if it is the kid that's actually
calling us Booker replied her and worth
exchanging a worried glance at each
other you two know something don't you
Jerry demanded does that thing from the
outside does it have my son too Dad
another voice called Jerry froze his
blood as cold as the Mind tunnel he
stood in he hadn't heard that voice in
almost a year but recognized it
immediately it was Carly his daughter it
seemed impossible he knew she had been
merged into part of SCP 001a when day
broke but now she was somehow calling
out to Jerry her voice sounded clearer
like it had used to before she changed
and she wasn't trying to lure her father
out into the sunlight either for a
moment it seemed to Jerry like his
daughter had somehow come back Dad we're
both over here Carly's voice called
again we need your help Kyle's stuck
who's that Booker whispered that's Carly
Jerry sniffed holding back tears you
said your daughter became a part of scp1
daa worth pointed out M maybe she got
better the father asked hopefully I hate
to say it but that's definitely not her
Sergeant Booker replied we should turn
back now if there's an anomaly in these
tunnels that's not going to be pretty
for any of us she added turning to worth
what Jerry yelled what do you mean by
that look buddy those aren't your
children the MTF agent said bluntly it
sound like scp1 d got them no no the the
voices are too clear worth replied I
think something else is in here before
Jerry could explode with anger at how
uninterested both Foundation personnels
seemed at the fate of his children
another sound Was Heard footsteps
something shuffling closer pading its
feet on the stone there was a low growl
that filled the tunnel as whatever it
was came closer still dad the voice of
Carly repeated sounding only a few feet
away now where are you Dad Kyle's voice
immediately followed it behind came the
sound of Booker striking a flare as it
erupted into a plume of and heat she
threw it down the tunnel and there they
were not Jerry's children but instead a
pair of nightmarish creatures they
backed away from the flare slightly the
light still illuminated their blood red
forms walking on all fours like wolves
the creatures elongated heads were
missing any eyes just Jaws filled with
rows of sharp Red Fangs dad came Kyle's
voice again emanating from one of the
monsters it was mimicking Jerry's son
both of his kids even having seen SCP
001a at a distance the father could
barely believe his eyes 939 Booker
yelled the second her flare illuminated
them run she pulled a sidearm and opened
fire the bang of each shot ringing
loudly through the tunnel the pair of
939 pounced at her while Jerry and worth
turned to run back the way they had come
as the creatures attacked The Echoes of
gunfire were replaced with blood
curdling screams what the hell are those
things Jerry yelled in a panic CP 939
researcher worth panted too much to
explain they're pack hunters and they're
and they're vicious what about Kyle and
Carly I heard their voices that's what
those monsters do they mimic human
speech to draw us out we're their prey
there's no telling how long they've been
down here they might have retreated to
the mine to avoid the sun on the surface
worth yelled the sound of the SCP 939
getting closer were catching up right on
Jerry and Worth's heels why would they
come down here for the Mind worker
huffed slightly ahead of the researcher
given his slightly stronger physique to
escape the sunlight worth replied SCP
939 tap
Bri his sentence was overtaken by a
scream as one of the blood red creatures
caught worth by the ankle knocking him
down and pulling him back to be devoured
Jerry didn't look back he just kept
running back through the tunnel the
sound of SCP 939 calling after him in
Kyle and Carly's voices made it even
harder not to stop in turn even just for
a second but he reminded himself that if
he stopped running then he couldn't lure
the creature out of the mine and into
the sunlight it wasn't how he'd ever
wanted to go out but maybe that way
Jerry would see his kids again now go
and check out scp1 can SCP 049 finally
cure when day breaks and SCP 001 when
day breaks SCP 682 for more horrifying
when Daybreak scenarios